so we've got two of the funniest people
on YouTube today and two
guests uh Steven
Tes oh thank you very much for coming on
it's my pleasure thanks very much I've
seen a bit too much of you recently I
know we SE twice week yeah too much
before that we'd met once yes and I
forgot I'd met you yeah twice as quite a
lot of Lawrence I usually stick to the
once if we can help it that's it this
that's enough really underneath the
travel podcast that we released it said
um
oh and I thought I thought this was a
bit weird oh poor Jordi having to go
away for a week with Lawrence I was like
if only you knew if only you definitely
suffered more than I did yeah 100% yeah
but like it was annoying for us but
anyway we've done we've done the TR the
travel and [__] to death now yeah onto
the fun no one gives a [__] you got any
more travels coming up um we we'd like
to we were supposed to go uh jued
America we were supposed to kind of we
were penell in go with with them on that
and um a little video called Samy AZ
loves [__] ruin that for us the
NFL makes sense they weren't Happ about
which I thought America got CH getting
that tit Out Left Right In sent on that
they should be aware of it well saman
azri officially didn't [__] anyone we
don't know that it just his girlfriend
say sam who's a
virgin he didn't [__] anyone around that
time I don't know just his girlfriend
between these dates I've been legally
told to say allegedly yeah um how do you
guys stay out of legal issues do you
have any no I I I don't know anything
bad until yeah at some point though when
you get a certain amount of people
watching your videos that's when it like
people start to give a [__] yeah like
legally yeah I'm sure well when we had
JJ on last time he's obviously having to
be like careful about what he about what
he says and that might come to you one
day you have to be you might have to be
careful no you seem like quite a
wholesome guy yeah have you ever said
[__] in a video I don't think I have do
you want to say it now just to get off
your chest I'll save it yeah it'll come
at some point stay tuned for that guys I
just every camera going there that's
very good I like how he things keep them
listening Revenue keep the for later we
did that with Spencer we saved that for
a good an hour into it yeah really
dropped the the sa bombb on them um
creatively speaking should we go into
that you are seem quite interested in
talking I watch I've got to Adit I'm a
fan of both of you yeah I watch both
your religious religiously true Jack
sort of satisfies uh my quench my thirst
in hating certain YouTubers and it's I
usually hate the same people he hates so
like recently and I've never even heard
of this [__] he did a video about
someone someone Pro Gamer or someone
gamer yeah I didn't know who he was
until a couple of days ago I mean I kind
of hate you for sort of telling me about
that what a Ned what he's got over a
million sub over a million subscribers
this absolute C I think the uh correct
term is [__] Destroyer yeah that's what
he oh that
guy well yeah um the least talented
person and I mean there's a long list of
talentless [__] in the million club and
it sort of pisses me off that none of us
are and that [__] is have you seen how
many views he's getting noce have you
not what is it I just relied on you to
tell me everything I needed to talking
every upload 4 million 5 million what
are you if you're what are you doing
with your life watching this what's it
called Pro Gamer
J I see I'm not a jealous person but
then so I could give a [__] that he's
getting that it's it's more the fact
that like well it's just not fair
there's no justice is it you see you see
them them amount of views and you think
like who are these people but then
you've only got to look at the world and
look who's in charge of America and
there's a [__] lot of them out there
it's about branding isn't it it is about
branding because well no because Pro
he's professional gamer tick Jay you got
the weed side down he's got everything
in his name do you know what I mean he's
he's cool he's edgy he's a [__]
Destroyer yeah uh you know I mean how do
you stay away from those pitfalls I mean
the the actual the video that shows up
when you look on his channel is him with
his head inside what can be described as
a condom I guess um if only he kept it
on did you see how how encouraging to
kill himself he can charge an any device
with a potato I saw that that was yeah
that was next level that yeah that did
actually piss me off a little bit
because I will click videos like that
just in case I do to his main
demographic yeah basically yeah he a
gullible enough to go potato and just
sort of you know I mean you know it's
true no but it is true I mean that's
that's the thing that pisses me off is
there are a lot of people who really
grind out there and then the other
people who go can't walk my [__] out
today okay
ready okay guys hey guys back again for
another n yeah oh God yeah there's
another one out there no now do you ever
feel bad I mean you don't really have a
go at anyone You parody people which I
quite like shows how observant you are
in your comedy I quite you're both
observant but in different ways do you
know I mean I think Jack's more
aggressive which that's what I quite
like about that but but it's still it's
aggression but it's sort of focused
aggression you know it's like George
Bush aggression do you know what I mean
when he strikes he really does when he
strikes he'll [__] your country up do
you know what I mean yeah a path of
Destruction yeah I'll take it yeah throw
game of J very much like
[Laughter]
Iraq [__] up he is actually quite good
like when I watched this I thought why
is he on it but when you're here you're
like yeah he's good when you get there
you sit down you understand [__] is he
doing yeah and then you look through the
comments say they're so contrasted it's
the [__] and the big one he funny yeah
it's decent yeah we' we've sort of
stumbled onto something really people
think that I actually knew the whole
time exactly what was going to happen as
soon as I picked him up do you know why
this this is the honest truth of why I
knew this would work cuz when we met
each other did the football Republic we
would do a game of two halls you've just
done that actually yeah yeah still on it
and um we would talk for about half an
hour cuz we'd have to wait for ages for
people to get their [__] together and
that and do the actual questions and I
realized that the half an hour me and
him just start talking on Skype was much
better than what we were uploading so I
was like and that's the quality of the
football Republic just a few uh no the
offense to the lads cuz actually no Adam
B was a producer rip this is still his
job but the point is I just knew I just
knew I thought that's better if we
upload that that would get more of it
but people don't want to hear us talking
about whatever we think you can't put
prizes in that there's no game show in
that so turns out the priz is just to 2
hours of good content which went to
number one on iTunes first week so they
get back there since they missed out
wait till this one the thing is I've
sort of given up on iTunes to be honest
because um there's just no money in it
to be honest there is no M oh there is
money in it it's just going into my
account yeah
yeah oh dear just I'm not saying any of
it it's relative I got to log into your
channel the other so you rev you anyway
uh you are creative in many ways aren't
you yeah it's bit like desert and discs
um
when you when so for instance I like
your chicken connoisseur video I thought
that was quite good yeah that was the
first one I seen and then I sort of went
back really and I was like oh this this
guy you were you were quite late to the
very late to the St T originally you
were a rugby Channel weren't you stepen
Tes take that one off your post not that
didn't thank you um and then you decided
to go to Comedy why yeah um I I just we
did like CU I did a comedy degree at
University and I thought braging yeah
you know it's can you actually do is
that no no no it's a genuine thing
didn't defer to do economics or
something no a comedy degree yeah I mean
it's not self-evident but sure no no I'm
not not in the line I'm just I just no
I'm with what is a comedy degree like
it's it's like drama it's like a drama
course but uh more [__] like yeah we had
to do clowning one week no the very
first lesson uh the teacher went okay
right everyone take your shoes off and
this is like you know 20y olds doing it
and then he went okay like get on all
fours and pretend to be a cat and at
that point I realized you know I've just
this isn't for
me yeah n Grand
a me I wonder if that that must be the
same what was that guy in Big Brother
George Osborne was it oh God yeah he
must have taken that course you know you
remember that would you like
mege George Galloway George Gallow was a
he still goes around London as a
c yeah not the tree
anyways politically is now um so uh CU
there is interesting about more to this
because like I I did like courses and
that and we never got told take my shoes
off and act like a c um no I did a
diving course I'm just thinking
different fields no but it's like I've
done a course and they never asked me to
take my shoes what what was I went to
University for a day and I didn't one
what was your reaction when they said
that like what you just say I was just
like genuinely an hour like I ran got my
dad's head I think I'm coming home
really well I said they made me take my
shoes off there's a guy called Jamal
Maddox he's like he's been on live at
the Apollo now he was in my he was on my
course and he refused to take his shoes
off he said he's got athletes foot that
seemed more yeah that was more dignified
than actually having to take your shoes
off well what's wrong with taking your
shoes off it's
just at what point does that yeah
promote comedy so did you Jack the C in
no I I stuck with it because I thought
thought of P it now thought you have
known and then basically what like in
the third year they let us do what we
wanted really so
I do what you think put your shoes on if
you want [__] it do what you think Grand
you do you
yeah and so I did we tried our best and
you guys are all bollocks so do what you
like all right so you're not comedians
like do they all have to go through or
can you just can you just R up on stage
and you're a comedian or comedians doing
this course now no honestly it's like I
learned a lot more outside the course
like I I started doing standup outside
the course I learned so much more just
doing what I wanted to do um and in the
third year it was all do what you want
yourself so it was I started writing
myself so the the good part of the uni
course was the people that were on it
and getting to use the equipment that
was about it that is part of uni though
isn't it is that sort of experience of
you you wouldn't be in the same room as
all those people if you hadn't have paid
the N Grand a year to be in there and
that but that's part of it yeah I guess
you wouldn't so you maybe you would have
sort of you know gone into an office job
or something and be like [__] it I can't
work do you see do your parents still
see that as a waste of money or no
because uh they
excellent they they they don't speak to
me anyway
so
Mom uh but yeah so so I just did this
like sketch uh and we put it together
filmed it all it was about half an hour
and it was like the bake off and we
ripped top of few like the office and
stuff it was it wasn't the best there's
nothing wrong with
that some people make a career out of
that soon as you said that I was like
looking away yeah what is it like to be
Ricky J's
impersonated I don't know I'll ask him
next time I see him oh good me to them
you've seen the video Rick it's actually
one of my favorite interviews I think
what actually what was it like meeting
the person that you sort of idolize and
that and and try to interview him and be
like oh yeah like M with them you
were're on the same level here I love
the way you at the start the way you try
and put your arm around him is similar
to the way that Gareth does that thing
in the office you know and Gareth is
with the girliest yeah yeah clear yeah
uh no I was I was [__] myself yeah
but it's I don't know going to run the
risk of sounding quite cheesy but he was
so warm yeah so it like it just relaxed
me straight away the first minute was
[__] awkward cuz I did I did
basically I always sort of say yeah I
went for a cuddle yeah and he and very
much like that he didn't move and he
didn't embrace it and it was kind of
like okay oh this is going to be this is
going to be long did you sort of tell
him like you're a big inspiration to me
and blah blah blah or did you not even
mention any of you could sort of tell
though you you could tell it was it was
mental yeah because he he we organized
the the interview me and him like first
of all when I first asked he was like
just go for an agent and then in the end
it was like okay well they're powering
me off he's like right [__] it so we
sorted it out and then when we were
chatting we had about 5 minutes to chat
before we did the interview and I was
saying little things and he was coming
back with these replies which was mental
because it was like he's seen a lot of
my videos because I I as soon as he come
in I was like sorry mate I'm the guy
that's always on your case um to do this
and he was like no no you're right jack
I'm I'm glad we could finally get it in
and then I'd say something about my
granddad throughout and I was like I'm
not going to repeat what my granddad
said and he said no not your granddad I
how the [__] how the [__] do you know
he's excellent at reading people and
pretending to know what they've done in
yeah yeah yeah yeah know yeah especially
not your
granddad that must have been quite a
surreal experience though was it like
yeah it mad after you got it done were
you a little bit like [__] me I did it
yeah it was like Cloud n cuz uh I went
back and saw some of my old tweets and
there was one from 2009 and it was like
Ricky of a is my inspiration there was
another one that was like I'm going to
do something with Ricky jaas one day and
then before he come in the room cuz he
was like 20 minutes late he's allowed to
he's Ricky face not slagging him off and
uh and then after it was done it was
like my whole career had led up to that
and don't [__] it up don't [__] it up
and then as it it went really well yeah
and then after it was kind of like f
what now yeah it would Jord it would
have probably felt was it a little bit
like [__] hell but you're a little
bit like I've done it I I did what I
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah cuz he was the
sort of Pinnacle for you I guess yeah
yeah yeah I also I love uh I love the
bit where's talking the jump Cuts
there's so many little moments in there
where it's sort of different to like an
nma interview or something like that do
you know what I mean there are other
ones which a bit more formal you tell
he's totally relax and just having a
chat which is quite nice at the start he
wasn't um relaxed and then there was a
bit I did in it um which was quickfire
questions that was great and uh
basically I start off by saying cats or
dogs and he's genuinely gets pissed off
in the video it looks like he's acting
but he got pissed off and I could feel
myself losing it a little bit I was like
cats or dogs and oh for [__] sake I've
got a cat and I went but you like dogs
but the joke was that they were quick
five questions that progressively got
more and more shits as they go on I was
very aware that they were [__] questions
and then I went Twitter or Facebook and
he was like Twitter and then at the end
he he cracked up cuz obviously I got to
the [__] ones and then he sort of said
right just don't go in and then he was
like I didn't know they that they were
[__] ones he went someone through there
it was a press St who's obviously doing
Mo genuinely asked me the same [__]
question cats or dogs Facebook or
Twitter so it was so good that I could
finally get the punch line otherwise I
would have [__] it all then and there
people would just thought it was a
really awkward
interview tone yeah yeah but um a bit
that I cut out because you can do that
on YouTube um he asked me what I thought
of life on the road and I went oh [__]
like that and he didn't react yeah and
then I went well no it's great that's
why you're here like that and then he
was like yeah yeah and I was like I'm
going to have to [__] pull this out
of my ass but then obviously as it went
cuz is
sh the worst no I really like it no is a
really good film it really nice the
thing is you
can you can really tell that he's not
working with Steve Merchant anymore when
you watch life on the road
because I think in any creative sense
when you've got two people who are uh
very good working together it'll always
be better than when that's that one
person on their own usually if they're
as funny as those two are and same on
this channel yeah I feel like no admit
like if I've got a good a video idea
I'll talk to you before I go ahead and
do cuz two minds are better than one and
don't get us wrong it is very funny but
it's just it's not office funny at all
like it's definitely it's a different
kind it's a bit it's a bit more
Hollywood funny it's a bit more
mainstream funny whereas you could tell
the office was a really it was like a
really refined strain of Comedy wasn't
it that was it was clearly a labor of
love do you know what I mean which you
often find a lot of this the thing with
YouTubers and a lot of those guys you
can tell like you can tell in your
videos you've clearly put a lot of
effort into it and there's a lot of
graph that's gone into that as opposed
to other guys who sort of go right they
[__] another video out and see what
happens do you know what I mean and same
like that observational humor is quite
difficult to nail I just feel like the
the sit it wasn't that it wasn't as
funny it was the situations didn't
really make as much sense yeah I I was
like can't say anything no it I did I
did love it and I i' love what J do I
loved all all of his stuff but I feel
like it's just very that's the most
obvious way I've been like is this the
film or they yeah the film I really
missed Merchant like just just to give
um the situations better context and
things like it just seemed a little bit
like I like the bits where like he was
trying to get on the bus and all the
rest of it it wasn't there wasn't any of
it where I was like oh that was crap but
I just felt like it was lacking
something I feel like there's been a
change in in Ricky's writing whether it
is the merchant thing or not where he
puts a lot more heart into it now yeah
so der definitely was that and then the
film had like elements of Derek bit more
emotional in that as well but his films
like he always seems to tear up like is
it the the invention of line or where
his mom dies yeah and it it made me cry
cuzz he is a good actor and he wanted to
show that I think Derek was underrated
like as a as a story just not not
because it wasn't just about being funny
it was actually a really good story yeah
it was quite sweet in that sense no one
has really covered that sort of thing
before all
home sort of brave enough to kind of
almost be like right I'm not I'm not
autistic but I will play this character
in quite a comedic way it can come off
as a bit pissy otherwise it could look
really bad like some could have been
like I can't believe he sunk this loan I
mean he's gone for this subject matter
but it's very clear but it shows where
he's coming from where at one point I
think someone says have you been tested
and he goes well will it change who I am
and he goes no he W don't worry about it
yeah yeah which is that that's so that's
so clearly a reflection of like his
early stuff like on the podcast is quite
philosophical about things like who are
you and those sort of things I thought
it was quite sweet but everything jice
has done I think with the best comedy
it's like you do what you know yeah so
if you look at the subjects he's chosen
um a struggling actor trying to get a
series off the ground and uh extras uh
Derek is an all people home I'm pretty
sure he said his family have worked in
that obviously the office he worked in
an office like uh everything seems to be
like what he knows um and I think that's
pilton well yeah pretty much and just
pil I mean that is a stroke of Genius in
that sense because there's not you know
most other people wouldn't make their
producer into that feature and sort of
then get them essentially a career and
millions of pounds out of it you're
going to do it on you pretty much that's
sort of that's s of you're my pil then
you I was on a kids show the other day I
was on the footb beond borders and they
were we could get we could get we
couldn't get true Jordy so you got the
next best thing and I was like where is
he oh my God turns out I was the next
best thing you your work's definitely
gone up since doing this with me it's
you made more money out of it sure so
thank me later yeah right
um but then with you your writing
process must be different cuz obviously
Jack's on his own and you can to that's
Jack's character do you know what I mean
whereas you've got two other guys as
well sometimes three yeah I the how do
you know those guys uh they were on the
course really with me how they doing who
graduated with the highest Mark uh some
of the out of us it was me sure but is
that why you name the channel no I did
it Cu uh you know it's just it's I'm a
narcissist I just I love myself and I
thought what did Max get in the perfect
he got he got a 2-1 and he passed like 6
months after everyone else okay cuz he
he didn't hand something in yeah he's
incompetent so that's why you throw him
in the river in every sketch you beat
him up quite he's the big hairy guy yeah
who gets the football off the head I
mean I'm a little bit better shaped than
him no offense M if you're watching I
like good stuff yeah um but yeah you're
the star of the show yeah well like it's
because they've got jobs I'm the one who
writes it cuz I can't expect them to
write cuz they've got jobs so I write it
and comedy jobs edit stuff
bar work so you know they might make a
few jokes it's up to
them just
SM that's true though isn't it like
there's obviously there's sort of uh you
can tell because I obviously it's your
channel but there's you tune in for all
those different characters so when you
write it and then do they come along go
well I'm not saying that I'll say no no
they're really good they'll they'll do
anything you seen some of the [__] that
that Max I can't imagine this m she
turns down yeah he well he didn't have a
job to begin with uh and he was really
poor so he'd do anything for a quid
for a quid one quid it's like to be fair
we get a lot of that on YouTube there
those girls who got the tit out on FIFA
so you just got to get the money
anywhere you can it quite literally if
they're pregnant but they're looking I
don't think that's ever
been I tell you're not doing it you're
not doing it but once this scores out
someone will sure there's probably a 12y
old J no not JM jmx yeah yeah
jmx anyway I love his face no JM a love
I don't want him to shoot me
no you guys can deal with that
later but the point is with your Stu you
right yeah yeah and then do you just you
how do you shoot it do you think it's a
professional operation not at all no
it's it's h it's we just do the best
with what we can I I think the main
people watch my channel hopefully for
the jokes and doesn't matter whether
it's filmed with an iPhone or whatever
that's what they're there to see you've
done one professional one though haven't
you yeah thanks to your uh my great team
it a really good try yeah thank you P
the pun and uh which one was that the
one where he interviews him and then he
sort of gets a bit pissed off it's it is
actually very funny you can sort of tell
both of you trying to put in a show
stealing performance yeah um who you
think won Max at the end still a little
bit like now we play them off against
each other thought ahead
this is very similar to that potent V
interview did a few weeks ago few months
ago now um so but you know that whole
thing with the cats that got me into
thinking about um have you ever heard
about what Ali G or like sash Baron
Cohen did he went to that school of
Comedy where they sort of just is that
France I don't know apparently I think
it could be a french guy and they he
tells you to find your inner idiot and
that's where sash BR gets all his
characters from is he starts and he
makes them as ridiculous as possible and
that was part of his exercise and he
came up with all these purely from just
trying to find and be the biggest idiot
because he was saying that like that
idiot side sort of reflects on a lot of
human traits which he sort of brings out
in all his characters yeah there was
rumors that he when he made Borat stayed
in character from he did a long time to
the point where his model girlfriend was
having to like tolerate him acting like
that at night with her and that she's
a something like that pretty girl
whatever um and yeah he was like
literally in character the whole time
lady imagine that w we were I think well
quite literally I think they were away
on a triple though weren't they so I
that she sort of traveling with him I
bet I bet it's just sort like really
intensive shooting then he gets to go
home do you ever do
[Music]
that for
once never again then did you edit them
yeah yeah just on your own you believe
it would you but yeah what you Ed him uh
Premier Pro good choice oh are you a
final cut X guy I yeah yeah wow you and
Alfie like that yeah you get any tips
from him from him yeah not really have
have you had any backlash from cuz uh
the video you did about Alfie Alfie days
for those who don't know um vlogger
great Channel go take a look pointless
Vlog Vlogs it's called [__] off
pointless vog always promote people I
don't
want pointless is definitely the the
right word for it is quite funny though
that he's called them pointless vlogs
it sort of tells it's almost like he's a
parody it it wouldn't surprise me after
like a few years if he came out and like
it's a car after whole thing if he did
that I'd have to delete my channel
because I'd be like you are the most
self-aware comedian I've ever met yeah
and like literally someone sort of like
he did like an actual where he's just
like actually like Ted up the fot we you
actually bought that you stupid cuns you
[__] stupid 12-year-old [__] you've
been watching this a whole time buying
my [__] my stupid same [__] poers I
hope you bought them you stupid [__]
maybe the pointless B it's invisible but
it's just got like SW stickers in white
ink printed we all all 12y olds are just
reading that yeah for some reason I love
Donald Trump all a
sudden so have you had any backlash at
because I know he's beloved that that
lad isn't he um yeah he is and he's got
a few few followers under his belt um
see I posted the video about him on
Monday and then my followers [__]
loved it and then
up uh and then I think recently I
checked this morning um my Alfie video
is now appearing and recommended on his
videos so people are like watching all
of his Vlogs loving it um before school
and you should have put a picture of him
in the thumbnail why did you not do that
because I I don't know like people say
it's like click baity yeah definitely it
is a bit click baity like obviously I'm
using a big YouTuber's name to get views
but it's not the whole reason why I
genuinely dislike his content so I'm
going to I'm going to I'm going to say
it no his content is utter [__] wank
yeah but I mean it's the same as sort of
watching you know it's not your audience
you no but if so for example if God I
hope it doesn't happen I ever get like
caught somewhere and
tortured they would have me watch his
Vlogs make a note of that ala you know
um sort of match sticks over the eyes
just watching Alfie days it's just he
it's how can he be truthful how can that
be the actual personality of why not I
think you you lived such a hard life
that you think that everyone else this
[__] eat unicorn poo
oh and I'm like that was a funny [__]
hell mate like if he grew up where I
lived he would have been dead before he
even made 10 years old do you know what
I mean he be doing ballet yeah Billy
Elliott he's the exception I saw an
interview and he was on this morning and
uh he was talking about his very first
video that he made he was on this
morning I do love when the BBC and ITV
have vloggers on because they treat them
as if they have they do [__] gold so
they're like and how do you do it it's
just so inspirational the way that you
put all these you can tell the producers
behind the camera going [__] yeah oh we
put this [__] 10-minute news package
together which includes bombs and Iraq
and Kosovo and all these all these
horrible places we just informed you of
something awful how do you cut together
a loot of stuff how you cut together
baroa montages do how do you try
American candy every exactly
yeah genuinely you know and you can tell
the TV people oh for [__] sake yeah
yeah he was he was talking about his
very first video that he made and it was
him playing Monopoly by
himself [__] more tragic Jesus he's
definitely he was better on day one I
can
ask is somewhat interesting do you know
what I mean yeah all downhill from
Monopoly you feel do you feel a little
bit guilty afterwards you sort of feel a
bit like you know people ask me that
question and it's like it's not like
it's not like I'm attacking a
15-year-old who's just started a YouTube
channel he's a [__] millionaire will
does that mainly so that he's got that M
would will he does attack nobody's that
you know it's brilliant that is if
you're going to do that start as you
mean to go on find a load of people who
are already being piled in on and just
add more ha
yeah yeah he's a millionaire he lives in
a [__] Mansion he [__] Zoella well I
mean allegedly why do you have to put it
allegedly what she Fu she [__] him yeah
no but it's a little bit like when
Michael Jackson was with um it's nothing
like bubbles Michael Jackson was with
Priscilla you know no cuz I remember
when Michael Jackson got married and I
was like something just doesn't seem
right about this do you know what I mean
I'm just
not I'm not quite sure and cuz I can't
imagine my Jackson getting erection over
a woman and I have the same issue with
Alfie de I'm not saying that he doesn't
I'm just I just can't not that I would
want to imagine it but I couldn't even
if I wanted to how hard have you
tried I couldn't I could can can you
really imagine him bending a woman over
and [__] and going I take that you
can't can you you can't Alfie days would
not [__] a woman like I sort of feel
like I need to defend Alie a little bit
I feel like you feel the
same I think uh you know I look into
that that beautifully swept fringe of
his and I think God he knows how to
Rattle a lady
yeah that's so do you know I I guess
what I'm saying is I never watched news
round as a kid and thought Oh is Otis
going to Rattle a woman after this I
just thought thanks for the news Otis
onto blue you look at and you just think
I mean she's not the best looking L I've
ever seen by any means but um oh come on
just keep putting the boot she's lovely
no I'm not saying she's not I'm saying
it's not like she's a 10 I she's we
about she probably thinks she's well out
my league and I mean on that kind of she
probably is she probably thinks
that she not me I she's so up herself
and remember what I think is the most
important thing to me but what I'm
saying is the of room she walked out
where where he's gone half those
women gone that was genuinely just a
toilet I could imagine I just can't
imagine like what she SE them they were
together before they got big though I
mean that's the thing is they were
together before Alie is that why he gets
away with a p like
that no he does though doesn't
he you have all the money in the world
you can't someone's Dental condition is
really Dent definitely is
Dental no it's like think Kanye West
sitting over here his Channel's like
Through the Wire every
week but no it's it's not it's not I
don't know what's going on but it's it's
just the way his mouth moves it's it's
annoying yeah no he is speaking Yeah
it's you know that video that I briefly
touched on in in um when basically
they're moaning about kids taking
pictures of them Little Joe well episode
wasn't it you know when Joe had that
thing he regretted and apologized for
but they never did no but Joe actually
said what he meant he didn't skirt
around it like [__] in this C did he
yeah yeah it was like uh they're quite
passive aggressive in it which I quite
liked because like go on be yourself be
you really are [__] you're sitting
there go this is
great yeah and so he was um there's
there's a bit where she's like oh yeah I
love taking um pictures of random people
and random food in a restaurant you Vlog
every day you film everything you you
are that person like the only stop
vlogging when they go for [__] and
actually that's probably the only time
that they actually create anything
decent [__] I do think though that
that they are I'm kidding I'm kidding I
love her makeup stuff I love all that
yeah great people do great things it is
sort of a hard thing I mean it's hard
because the YouTube industry is based
almost entirely on white people having
fun um and they did you see that the
other day in that um that video um this
this lad created a video about a
magazine that had being released of all
the biggest YouTubers in the UK and it
was like basically 30 white people and
they all look identical and and this uh
this lad did a video who happened to be
black himself and he was was like no
deji and no JJ yeah like the two biggest
YouTubers in the [__] country and and
they were like oh they they don't create
the kind of content our readers will and
it's like how do you [__] know that
how do you know that that is it is a bit
like that though isn't it even it's not
even that even if you're working class
you kind of get in a magazine what's
wrong with me you [__] eh GQ can do a
lovely tidy up version on you could just
start with me Brian came in and Brian
was gross now we sorted him out you know
that could be video to be fair it
probably would actually make a very good
video you know that where they sort of
cleaning this up like got Wan sort of
thing yeah qu ey for the straight guy
yeah stay how you are I like it change
thank you that could be a sketch well
get G on yeah well I would do a sketch
with you I'm quite a good act I love how
many people say that to you I'll do a
sketch with
you with me I could bring some views so
help you out
whatever I actually I really like the
chicken
video though that was actually genius
and you hit right at the right [__]
moment which is important as well cuz
that was when he was sort of having his
15 minutes and that yeah um he was about
12 minutes in at that point so you got
you got in there just before
cont before you run out of chicken to
sample run out what did he do after what
is he do no chicken con I saw him
presenting um a video on a different
YouTube channel and it was just all
about trainers that made it seem like
his day all day about
that what I talk check out this sick
crap I don't know it was just all about
trainers though but the top comment was
like why are you reviewing trainers
stick to what you [__] know he's done
a couple of videos about chicken and now
that's all he's ever allowed to do that
is YouTube comments you ever try
anything different what the [__] are you
doing what are you I remember when I
moved from just from being on the couch
on the worst uh camera ever drinking a
beer and it's like this green screen
lock I just can't stand it it's like
[__] hell mate I just want to make it
look a tiny bit better is that a oh he's
changed he's changed he's aspirational
now if you ever start doing sketches
they are going to bum I was I was out
honestly give it a we give it a we
spoiler yeah I was in I was in the pub
and there was like the Lord of New
Castle fansy I was having a drink and
there was a girl with her and these new
casts are like 40s 50s but they knew I
was that's one of the things I've got
over other YouTubers Northeast viral
yeah Northeast viral and he this this
one guy who really loved his to be fair
he's given his hug every 5 Seconds that
he's like oh you're great you're great
and then he goes in the ear of the girl
and he goes when you're alone later just
tell her we preferred him how he used to
be she's like unreal smashed us and he
goes but when you're alone when you're
alone what w awkward they don't people
don't like your change
have you changed much you blown up quite
quickly though haven't you so that's
really yeah it's only been like 6 months
so yeah done 8 years
so work good work no you have changed
quite a bit though like have I I think
mainly the jaw yeah you look different I
had a big op yeah did you did you not
know so why did his Through the Wire
joke get such a [__] laugh no I knew
you had bra I knew you had braces oh
yeah I know I O like that I had an under
bite and then the NHS sort of put it
back cing job on it looking looking shop
no but you generally changed though your
content a little bit more I think every
happens to everyone though you get a bit
more sharp you you sort of know what
you're good at and you horn that I did
really enjoy your your empty living room
or the empty sort of dining living room
area was quite a nice area it was quite
good so the background changed I was a
little bit upset I got to admit yeah
like I do I do like it when people are
funny about backgrounds on YouTube
aren't they oh aren't they just yeah
they really I mean now you've got the
the den the den yeah how's that going
it's all right it's all right it is a
little bit ironically zo Ellery with the
fairy lights and the you if you got
fairy lights on YouTube I mean who are
you do you know what I mean at this
point we were actually thinking about
having fairy lights here at one point I
wasn't no we were you remember when we
first designed the set and we went yeah
just put a table in there we make sure
there's cacti on it so it looks like
forel's show and then tell them the
references this all our idea yeah yeah
so original and then we were going to
have some uh too much budget turned out
yeah so you you've got success pretty
quick Steven yeah well you know I've
always been a [__] but it's so you
started like what was it 6 months ago
yeah in in July I had 600 subscribers
and then [__] me really yeah I mean
that's I've seen I've seen YouTubers
grow like will will GR very quickly U
but that's still [__] hellish like is
it I'm trying to remember what the first
I've seen he does like quite viral [__]
though your stuff tends to pick up
snowball it's uh I think it it was how
to be stormy um that was that went uni
lad used that yeah and uh and then after
that it's just a thought I'd actually
made a few after it anyway he did how to
be Conor McGregor as well which I
thought was funny very yeah yeah that
could have been better but it was uh
yeah I was going to think that the was
is that one of the curses of being the
comedian or so yeah I think you see joke
like jokes you miss and jokes that you
put in that just don't work by the time
you think yeah that'll that'll work with
it and it sort of kills it a bit but
that's what you learn from you know well
you're still young anyway what you're 21
I am ladies lots of time yeah um date
are there any ladies on the scene no
it's tragic the YouTube money you must
have changed [__] for you a little bit I
know Wheels definitely improved oh well
M he's got that jawline that ladies die
from well yeah that's that's the
ultimate YouTube jawline from it as
well but to sum it up I was on uh I was
on Tinder the other day having a great
time sure you were and I was just
swiping through uh and I found this
lovely lady 5 km away you know nice
little bus ride driving distance you got
a car yet no but I can I can drive I
like to have that you know but do you
have a car yet he's got the license if
he needs it if he gets checked for age
when buying alcohol
[Music]
sorted anyway 5K there she is Bam
sitting sitting duck as you thought
lovely lady I went into a you know what
what sort of pages we liked in common uh
admittedly I do like my own page Steven
T but she likes Steven T as well the
best thing about being a YouTuber and
being on Tinder you'd think that Swip
right [__] all okay I think never mind
you know that's one lost you know the
thing is that you must have looked at
that and thought Oh my God it can't be
him do you know someone must have copied
and pasted this from another page no cuz
my bio is yes it's me but that's exactly
what is it really no no of course it's
not what what is it just out of interest
uh I think it was something like uh I've
been through a lot of things in my life
but one of them wasn't puberty a
terrible joke but you know it sets the
tone that get a lot of swipes right do
you no
yeah then I was a bit depressed so I
thought the whole baby face thing you'd
be sort of kill the game you're not a
bad looking guy are you I think I am you
know these are covering up my ears you
got great you got your head I mean
credit to you your head's all in
proportion you know what I mean that's
when you buy it your head's all in
proportion that doesn't make you're we I
don't know
why um your children won't be hard to
squeeze
out ideal I'm sure that's what every
woman thinks of when they meet them is
give him birth to his children they'll
be tiny weak feeble I've always wanted a
feeble baby that might die anyway [__]
just infant just infant death there just
that's just where it's gone
post if you've lost a child this week
I'm sorry about that sorry guys sorry I
don't think they play this on the wards
do you know what I mean not anymore they
won't have you back we've heard about
that after that hospital radio yeah so
you swipe a lot yeah yeah so I was going
through it and then I found this uh this
account that was dedicated to the
character of chicken run called Babs oh
yeah yeah she's a great one yeah and I
thought well you know I'm game if you
are swiped right again nothing and I
just deleted the app through the phone
on the floor you need to me get some
professional shots of you something like
that you know I need to get head shots
yeah not those head shot guys before the
groomers start again yeah uh I think my
first video I ever saw R you was uh
things we all do on holiday oh no it's
not it was why I don't know actually is
that an old one you see I watched it you
can see he's been around the block I
have been around for quite a while yeah
you're sort of a weird one because he's
been on YouTube for [__] years but
you not actually got a YouTube channel
he's the fan that got lucky yeah so
lucky met all of them no that's um Joel
as M anyway which one exactly leave it
leave that one leave that one we'll
see and I can't remember your first
video but I definitely uh I remember um
one of Spencer's brother I think
Saunders was like you got to check this
guy out he's [__] yeah would have
been Saunders Saunders would tell anyone
that would cuz when Saunders finds a new
channel he's like you'll never guess
what it gets really
there's a young comedian right he's
bloody hilarious I love Saunders I think
mine of yours was the is it the 2010
World Cup did you do one about that is
that right I might have done [__] that
was a shot in the dark but
close might have done do one about the
internet you've done sort of you kind of
haven't done loads about football on
your own channel but you sort of do
football stuff don't you you've done SPO
in that haven you sure that football
stuff in yeah yeah recently yeah um
why'd you move into that really
monetizable Zone
uh um so I start I started a football
channel called 1080 football and then uh
yeah catch it 420 football nor nice I
like it Miss a trick there just as 4K
comes in you go get 1080 football never
guess what guys somebody genuinely
thought it was 1080 because 10 plus 80
equals 90 90 minutes of football no
that's never going to be
why good creative mind there yeah and
then um yeah and then a company me and
bought it off me and rebranded it to
spor wow and that was a nice five months
and now I'm here spending all that
cash yeah yeah spor good old spor cuz
spor were big weren't they and then you
sort of because some people think spor
is yours Sport's not mine no's not think
you look how angry is someone TW someone
tweeted saying what made him think of
starting SPO BBC sport I'd
imagine yeah no no they needed a YouTube
channel because they had the Twitter
they had the insta they were like a
banner account on Twitter yeah yeah yeah
and then they um they wanted me to
there's not enough of those is there
bander accounts on Twitter do you know
what annoys me do you know really get on
my [__] tits when something happens
in a match of football and one person
like the Pogba dab when Pogba gave away
a hand ball and it was like oh he dabbed
and every [__] Twitter account and
the dog all have to rush out and copy
the joke tweet the same [__] a
million of the bastards it's like was
hardly funny the first time I heard it
let alone the millionth time and all
these Twitter accounts try not to be
outdone I'm bored of you as all I'm
bored of a [__] lot of them but if
they want to pay me to be on there fine
great show me the you heard Joe who's
show me the money it's it's it's a hard
one because I I hate I obviously I love
Sport and whatnot but I love sport don't
technically agree with like just
tweeting the same [__] that all the
other accounts
it yeah but then some guys do that very
well though don't they some guys do they
find their own stuff and then everyone
else will copy it I think it's a bit
like everyone feed it's kind of hard to
know who is the unique one out of a lot
of them yeah you take it and you get
10,000 retweets it's hard to then go I'm
not going to do that anymore yeah cuz it
just EOS it's like py power like
sometimes they great they'll have some
really funny [__] like whoever runs
their account is decent yeah all 20 of
them um well yeah there's there's
definitely a few of them but then them
I've seen them steal people's tweets a
load of times as well so yeah it's
annoying isn't it sense well it's just
it's just that world in which we live in
like lad Bible like why why is that okay
like I know they pay 100 quid a video or
whatever but they still getting free
material and getting [__] Millions
like the amount they earn from it
compared to what they pay out I think
it's one of those business models though
isn't it we're getting quite deep deep
YouTube and Facebook here but it's one
of those business models where you go
we'll make enough money that when those
people come for us we can fight them off
in the courts you know just realized lad
B will actually owe me1 yeah my chicken
coniss Ser video so if you're watching
cough up I be able to sort that out for
you minute I've got a contact so he runs
the lad bar I'll just walk in there and
say I want me [__] 100 quid you [__]
yeah I I'm Steven
Travis I'm Max from Steven give me my100
just had a haircut F just the hair
that's the only thing you
I was just passing by It's s of annoying
that I was actually seeing Maxx's
ass way too many times yeah when he was
wanking off on the on the table and then
he's like you made the joke of something
like oh yeah that I put that in there
something like mayonnaise or some [__]
oh almond milk yeah yeah almond milk oh
yeah well it come from a
nut do so did you ever come up with
jokes on set or do you stick rigidly to
the script I've got like all the jokes
in the script usually get in cuz they're
gold let's be honest um but uh but I'll
let Max generally do what he wants
because he's uh he he's very funny
naturally he's probably one you should
get him on here good physical
com we like people who've got a bit of a
following if we can help oh he's got a
following mainly from you know various
investigators but he's uh he's really
good so it's because they there about
four hours we have to film so we stick
to the script pretty much but I'd like
to do something improvised in the future
I notic that on the last one you did uh
like you did the Joker and you all
dressed up and that and you're actually
quite a good actor like have you ever
thought about doing like proper acting
um non comedic just going in for an
audition it makes it makes me cringe
like I did it once for for an agency and
they said like do this script and it
about this scous kid who's lost his
parents or whatever and I did it this
monologue to the camera and it was all
right but it was just I hated doing it
because I have to get a laugh that's
what I like yeah but money is ideal as
well it's a divorce feels the void
getting a little bit deep now I mean
you've got something in common there
parents divorced yeah broken same broken
home um how about you broken same yeah
so all that's where comedy starts in the
home it starts in the home you you work
from Pain you know what I mean you
actually you generally find though
comedians when they do take on serious
roles they just seem to piss it cuz so
much easier than having the pressure of
being funny being funny is quite
difficult like you look at um was it
Robin Williams when he did serious stuff
he was [__] unbelievable yeah yeah
for that reason I think they say like
Jason Manford came on to the course one
day um just to you know take off his
shoes and stuff just to top
up and he was telling us about how uh
like cuz he does some serious acting as
well now he says does he coronation yeah
and something on bbcu but he says like
serious actors can't do comedy but
comedic actors can do series it's just
the way it works like maybe he's just
trying to build up his CV or whatever
age definitely is yeah funny guy though
Stephen you going to ask me about my
role or well you've actually written a
sick comp haven't you oh I've started
I've started in films buad Jes films
start yeah well Green Street 10 seconds
in uh what was it another no not another
Hood Brotherhood what's a new one
Brotherhood kood adulthood no
Brotherhood Brotherhood thank you
Brotherhood Brotherhood fully support
good just 10 seconds just a waiter my
favorite 10 seconds thank you dialog yes
I had to go up to n Clark's partner um
and ask her if she would like anything
else this is very different and you
winged it yeah I was a runner on the
show sorry we need someone in a tuxedo
to go over there something else they
would just happen to be rolling at the
time that's brilliant leave that in
that's fine we work in should you give
him the
money this is very different The Game of
Thrones acting questions we had isn't it
that was brilliant I've never seen Game
of Thrones but that was a great I but I
think I already got by well on that you
you I've seen enough that I know I've
seen enough that I know I sort of
covered the the show with that one and
held it together and I asked all the
other questions yeah what's your
favorite color yeah what's your favorite
what do you think of Alie D went back to
the javice question Facebook or
Twitter top of Jack's list
but is I mean uh do you guys cuz you've
sort of gotten out of YouTube a little
bit haven't you and you you you know you
get invited to places bit bit there yeah
what's the question don't any TV oh God
yes yeah I have many moons ago now what
was it then was it comedy C why are you
worrying come on cuz it is [__] well who
cares I I used to work in The
Butchers I used to clean like you know
green meat from like Grinders and things
should still had your self respect still
not worse than this yeah uh BBC 3 ever
heard of it when it was on TV I did a
show with my ex-girlfriend called Hotel
of mom and dad in which we had to move
out for the first time to see if we
could if we could do it in the big I'd
[__] I think I've seen that you know
like I think I've seen that show before
it was [__] is that where everyone
seems to like they basically crush and
burn and and then come crawling back to
Mom and Dad what wait what were you so
were you in the house with a load of
other people so basically it was
[__] but they they set it up as I
lived with her right parents or her mom
and I was just a dosser just on the I
wasn't I was on a good YouTube ad R back
then uh and um we had to they gave us a
flat and they they gave us the money to
spend it was meant to be our own money
to see if we could do it on our own
right but uh it was just car crash from
start to finish yeah you have to
basically budget everything and that I
remember watching that yeah yeah you
have essentially the BBC film normal
people living a normal life play it back
to themselves this is the same this is
the same company that gave um Tom Gray
show so you canot trust them that Tom
gry show is actually a really the L
Ventures thees we're going to get him on
at some point yeah he's good he's good
he entally a fourer people like you
definitely yeah but he he is the least
interested in YouTube YouTuber I've ever
met yeah not everyone's a YouTuber
though do you know what I mean he he
everything he does is on YouTube you're
a YouTuber do you not think I mean not
always sometimes you it's just sort of
like someone's going put that on YouTube
no if he had someone like managing him I
don't know if if he does if you if
you're a Tom G's manager I sympathize
and you're probably not doing a very
good job but like he is so talented
though he's so [__] funny I don't
know if you ever heard of his um Diaries
of when he used to play football on the
Spencer uh podcast great so [__]
funny um but he is he's good but he's
just no he just rocks up and he just
doesn't give a [__] basically great yeah
maybe we'll good story try and get him
on yeah is an E30 what is an E30 I don't
know I don't know he looks good no you
don't really you'll never know with him
like there's a am of times where we were
doing the Spencer show uh what was it
with the the game show yeah and he would
just turn up and he looked like he just
rolled out of a bin um isn't that sort
of comedian a lot of comedians look
quite disheveled though you know if
you've been on the circuit no there's
disheveled and then there's rolled out
of been not you know what I mean yeah
that's why I sometime I don't know
whether to take it offensively when
people go Lawrence is a bit like Tom you
go you're definitely not no you've got a
similar sense of humor but Tomy is very
funny very funny guy yeah um yeah now uh
but comedian wise you've done some
standup have you ever
done that show that I was telling about
BBC 3 one they um basically they sold it
is I'm just some YouTuber not making any
money living on a sofa play on FIFA
every day sure and then accurate no I've
never played FIFA no um it's fairly
accurate but they B they basically asked
me what what I wanted to be and this was
three four years ago so I just went
comedian stand up yeah last day of the
show Friday they went that they the
story arc was oh look Jack's going to
follow his dreams now he's moved out but
they told me on the day they said okay
we've set you up a gig tonight so you've
got to do some stand up and I was like
you're [__] kid at me so I went to
this Pub where they didn't have any
material um literally none I was just
going to read some tweets on my phone um
you remember Uber fact you remember that
on Twitter they were half of them were
[__] so I just thought I'll take the
piss out of that and I turned up at this
Pub not joking I thought I'd
accidentally signed up for a hidden
camera show because it was some shitty
Pub and Norwich I can't I couldn't even
tell you it was like and there was this
guy full grown man on the floor in a
suit crying so I'm like okay what's his
oh yeah he's just been to his dad's
funeral it's his wake
oh my [__] god and I've now got to do
stand up for the first yeah time ubera
the dead body reles and then I said to
the the the guy that run the P I said uh
how often do you do you do these every
week he's like do what the standup show
he went oh no no no just for the we
never had one in it before brilliant
okay I just stood in a corner read these
facts and this will be something new
yeah and then there was there was five
people stood there um and then my first
joke was something like not [__] it was
um statistically you're more likely to
fancy somebody if you don't laugh at
their jokes and then I looked at 5
people and they didn't laugh and I went
away and this guy just went oh I'm walk
off that was that was the BBC producer
at the
time that my girlfriend's dad what what
happened like what what so how was that
how was that them framed in the show did
they go oh Jack bombed or did they just
add a laughing track it looked [__] on
the show and it was even better like
they made it look better it still that
[__] there was another bit they me and
my girlfriend had only been together
like four or five months and they said
great time to commit on screen exactly
yeah they said for for this to work
we're going to have to say two years or
a year I can't remember it's a year or
two years and uh so I was like all right
but obviously I don't get into the
character of somebody who's been in a
relationship for 2 years so they took me
outside for a little Vox pop and they
was like um would you say you love your
girlfriend 4 months uh not really no
okay cool then they cuss it so Jack and
liy have been together two years do you
love her no and then and then when that
was on TV I was sat with her whole
family she didn't know what was coming
cuz I've done it outside didn't think
they'd use it they would't use that but
it would be [__] her mom and dad there
do you love your girlfriend no no I
don't I'm just say like I'm just here
for the
sex
just she F yeah oh no don't love her was
that so have you done standup since then
or no I did one uh one before that that
was my last yeah yeah I think I think
you retired at the right time then
YouTube's easier do you know what I mean
well I mean you can't hit you can't see
your audience you just sort of get all
these comments below that you deal with
or not and jump Cuts quite handy jump
Cuts really very handy you've done quite
a lot of standup yeah yeah you should
make it look that
way uh I started right at the beginning
of University and I finished at the end
I just haven't bothered with it since it
get a lot of good laughs on the shows
I've watched though yeah it like cuz I
was a bit of
a your jokes oh I love them yeah that's
that's what I brought to the table and
um lots of them right about what you
know you
are cuz he's a raging P he knows a lot
of them I do yeah great guys if you
watch him well the thing is with people
who never aged they can still provide a
thrill later on in life so it's ideal
who's your favorite through history yeah
um I've got the sticker
book I don't know great way to attract
kids got sticker book the murderer and
pedo sticker book
Merlin or as I call it Euro
96 Jes we've got the title of the
podcast anyway yeah who's your
[Music]
favorite you Tre special's your favorite
P I don't have a I don't have a favorite
I like them all equally yeah some of
them are gentl yeah for [__] sake it is
it is a horrible subject to cover really
isn't it it is
my next how to be is going to be based
have you ever seen like the pedophile
how pile Oh my God you you've spoken to
some pedophile Hunters the pedophile
Hunters s Stinson Hunter I'm going to do
a how to be of that okay Max feature if
you I wonder what his
character um we found a p we're going to
throw the river orig is that not going
to be very difficult no no just a load
of nons jokes is great where' you live
um St Helen so perfect h of it
yeah I've never been I've never been
this is the weirdest sh lovely part oh
fantastic yeah do you think you live
quite a sheltered life uh not anymore
now I've been exposed yeah yeah as a as
a ped yeah as a baby face Peter would be
the
ultimate he can blend within the crowds
he looks so young he was just hanging
out he's a 15-year-old there seems cool
guys what was it like growing up in was
did you grow up in St I was I lived in
Norwich for four years oh to both from
the same area and then uh then yeah
lived in St Allens for 17 went to
Salford uni so I lived there for a
little bit got mugged way that's fun
what was that like uh terrifying tip
with through the Stu by when he went in
the room they said take your shoes
off 27 grand for
a [__]
off a very long joke that we set oh I
like it when you bring it back now what
happened when you got actually moved
okay i' just been to a to a Liverpool
game and uh beat Swansea
32 story and uh and I was going back
from sofa from the train station and I
had all my stuff with me from the
weekend and uh my mom would gave me like
50 quids cuz uh you know she loved me
and I have my my iPad I sound so middle
class I deserve to get mugged here I had
like my little Liverpool bag and gloves
on cuz I thought you know I don't
conform to what they do in sford I'm
going to support Manchester United yeah
and I was walking walking down this like
main road but it was Pitch Black and no
cars were coming and this guy was
walking and he had he was completely
covered except for his eyes because he
wanted to see and I thought and my
literal thought was he looks like the
FIFA
Player and then just kept on walking and
he walked past I thought that's fine
that's what that's how Spencer afforded
all those just mugging people Alex was
filming it from the bushes you he a
laugh and uh and uh so he he went player
the
player he anyway have you got uh don't
forget to hashtag yeah as he running
away you really have to watch this this
will come across on and uh and so he so
he went hey mate have you got the time
and I said no so I was mugging him off
really I had an iPad an iPhone a watch
and uh I just kept on walking and then
out of nowhere he just came up to me and
he had a knife in his hand and he went
for [__] sake and he went give us your
phone now and I said already got
one can't use that one no I know my
number off by
AR yeah and I was panicking search
searching my coat and I genuinely
couldn't find it oh it was one of those
moments where it's like like you're
absolutely [__] Sweating Bullets cuz
you're frightened and he looked quite
Young looked younger than me that was
and it looked like he just literally
grabbed a kitchen knife and his mom was
like go and get your tea and you got any
money she went no get it for yourself so
he's gone out with his knife found me to
be fair those little Muppets are the
ones who usually kill people they're
like that's stupid he had they actually
go through with it do you know what I
mean great yeah so so I didn't I
couldn't find my phone and I went can I
give you money can I give you cash
instead Cod honestly Che to which you
replied no what is
I can't win can you believe me a muger
refus check
out can you
[__] there's a good one cuz then you get
the big YouTuber in the title as well
ideal all right Seb oh my [__] god so
I eventually there I pulled out a tenner
not a tampon and uh and I was shaking
gave it to him uh and he went you're a
[__] idiot and ran off so I had to go
to the corner shop for for protection
and I went I went to the car I've just
been mugged can to use your phone even
though I I have mine but I couldn't find
it and went oh yeah that happens a lot
mate use great [__] sake just 999 on
speed dial that's crazy called the
police I had to wait there for over an
hour like for a 10 yeah and uh what did
he look like well have you ever seen the
FIFA
Player oh love
yeah we just watching a few of his BS
yeah uh so that was awful uh where were
we before that just mostly what was it
like growing up in the area oh in St St
is great it's it's got a bad reputation
but it's it's just a typical what was
your school life like I
was I wasn't bullied and it's a mystery
to me start that way yeah I wasn't
bullied because I was I was I was obese
I must have been when I was like
10 until imagine him being [__] I was I
was really big I went for it you know I
didn't Mr kipin was like my dad and uh
it was uh it was amazing like the fact I
wasn't bullied honestly when you look at
me you think you deserved it mate cuz I
had this weird accent as well I didn't
fit in but I I did like weird
Impressions and I did Family Guy
impressions and that seemed to just get
me through like bullies would get me in
a headlock and say oh do you do you
Peter Griffin and then if they did it
they' let me go and it was like lads a
griffin oh I should have said Stewie
Griffin um do either I don't care one of
them n yes Stewie Griffin it's good
isn't it do you do that as well oh yes
Brian oh good and your name is Brian I
can't do any
[__] I do I do some off camera really
good impressions of just people we know
so that's yeah so you still live in N
don't you yeah what what was that like
grow up cuz I've like been through it's
it's very country is isn't it yeah
exactly how you imagine it that's what
it is never a little bit when I was
diving and that yeah do you like it that
was fine I never got mugs used to got
yeah never got mugs no there's not a lot
of people around to mug you any no I
used to do them I used to travel to St
Helens and mug people that's what I
did yeah what was it for you a school
M all right I was just bright Ginger and
had a massive jaw so didn't go well no
not the best ingredients for yeah but
apart from that not much yeah what's
your real hair color Ginge ging bright
sort of Fairly orange yeah what me
eyebrows no they're just like like a
Blondy sort of color oh yeah people
people tell me it's not as Ginge as I
think but then I think it's Ginge yeah I
me I can't really confirm color blind
anyway it's not really worth it yeah
what other YouTubers you guys all watch
who you you watch a lot of will don't
you
um the thing is I don't watch as much as
I'd like to like I'd like to watch like
more people but I've only just started
watching you YouTube sort of this year
brilliant yeah like I've always watched
a little bit but not enough really and
then I was like all right will only I
watch these two um but I've only just
come across you but I was like oh cuz
your reminded as a portridge yeah yeah
yeah and I'm a big portridge fan and I
just think that there's not enough like
young
unique YouTube creators I feel like
there's a lot of people who do the same
[__] and then the unique ones seem to
just get lost in the pile a little bit
so when you find a good one it's like oh
you subscribe [__] Diamond I do think
it's quite good in that sense cuz uh
like if you PBC that you know a lot of
the comedians quite similar there's a
lot of sort of Oxbridge comedians well
in order to get it's it feels to me like
in order to get anywhere you've got to
fit in with the people who have power
and all of those those people are that
how are these two middle class white
kids fit in with all those people have
power but even then like like if you
look at the sky sports thing like socker
is a classic example of um a show that's
needed changing for about 15 [__]
years but because the people in power
all p with the people who are on the
show they just keep changing like keep
would they keep the same people what
would you do I would scrap the whole
[__] show man it's needed scrap the
[__] 10 year and what would you do
after that make a brand new sure that is
totally [__] different and what what
football based but genius we'll bring it
from the '90s obviously it's going to be
a football show I'm talking about a new
football show but but just not a 1990s
football show that show literally has
not changed a jot in 20 [__] years
mate there's so much more you can do
with it isn't there Beauty behind that
though well it it used to be beautiful
before it had a this is what Helen
chamber um but anyway never mind what
would you do with it well I'll get rid
of head on chable and no offense
straight in straight take the jmx
approach no offense she's actually the
queen of um football like on TV and that
she's been doing a great job but she's
50 now or 49 or whatever it's time for
some new ideas new new thought Let's get
someone new in scrap the whole [__]
short ideally which woman would you have
why does it have to be a woman why could
why could I be two men
sexist let's have the agenda met yeah
[__] we haven't had a single woman on
this show yet and that's the way it's
staying yeah until we get someone worth
bringing on not quite sure if this is
parody at this point um is it so what
would you then I'm actually thinking
about should we have a woman on the
podcast but I don't know who which woman
would you like she doesn't have to speak
you just yeah just s of on a poll in the
background yeah what would you not that
I would before that um would you what
would you do with that
I'd like to get the problem is the way
men sit and talk women are a lot more
just generally reserved you seen loose
women I hate that show it needs to be
shot in the face to be fair D laughs
made a very good point about them the he
was like you know they're sitting there
talking about talking about sex with Tom
Jones whose wife died a year ago if this
shoe was on the other foot and this was
four men and a woman and the men were
talking to the woman about sex it would
be hell on he he he re he did the old
reverse sexism thing well no but it is
just like it isn't the old of it it's
totally true it's a pale of [__] but the
point is like to get a young intelligent
woman who you could have a good chat
with would be good do you know I just
can't can't find one can't find one at
least one with a good following that
going to bring something at the table I
love how we've got to a point in this
podcast where we sat around discussing a
Dappa laughs good point yeah Dappa laugh
made a very intelligent point was a
first for me I don't really know who the
BL I've never watched much of his stuff
to be honest sure you you would love it
I don't just put I don't know cuz I
think you're quite aware aware where oh
it's just yeah you told me he's [__] so
I probably wouldn't like it if it's [__]
I did a I did a sketch with him once um
I've I did a did a lot with him back
work no I like that keep
him yeah no I was um I was friends with
him back in the day
uh he like he he invited me to like my
first premiere and that so I was like
[__] this guy's well all right then
we did a sketch with
him just in WID just exactly the same
com but in WID sced oh he's cropped his
Vines [__] H oh dear and we um we
wrote when I was telling you off camera
that we did a sitcom sketch Channel and
um we wrote appals into one and um I
turned up I've been the camera crew
didn't like him before this game just
from his videos as you'd expect so to
convince them he's actually a well all
right guy and he's not da laughs he's
he's Dan and we turned up and um Dan's a
fantastic Dan's a great guy but we
turned up and uh he was just not a great
guy no not a great guy I went um do you
want the script Dan not expecting him to
know it but like do you want it and he
just went I'll just I'll just I went oh
have you read it he went no I'll just
I'll riff it he was pissed he I I'll
riff this I'll RI this scripted sketch
comedy you can't riff it and then um we
B out this this this back of this Pub
and this guy just walks in with his hood
up halfway through when we're filming
this sketch and I'm like sorry mate
we're just filming he's like [__] off oh
Dan brilliant throws a wallet Dan just
gets the wallet in the middle of the so
we're like we we'll do this in a minute
go to the bathroom wait 5 minutes come
back out at this point he's proper he's
all over the place he don't know what
he's talking about he's got some
19-year-old sat there this girl who
keeps laughing and rubbing him under the
table while we're filming it's it
couldn't have been more Dappa if you
tried and that was behind closed doors
that was off camera is that you going is
this you
riffing so our riic so she's going to
give me a hand you yeah so it's just
mental live the gimmick yeah live the
gimmick I I mean to be fair that there I
watched you know when it all blew up
yeah yeah yeah and again I feel B he's
obviously not here to defend himself but
he was there on yoube don't feel too
sorry for him he's probably a
millionaire M he makes a [__] ton of
money yeah he does I mean he did his he
did his tour you know essentially he was
the Donald Trump of Comedy for a while
um and you know it all blew up and I
thought let's watch a bit of this show
just see if see if it is his bad as
people say no it is the first episode is
him giving advice on how to get girls
proper moist now you already know about
this but you might be
interested then he finds a guy who looks
a little similar to you has a Bard sort
of he does that thing where you can only
be good-look if you look like everyone
else that's Snapper laughs the character
guessing I legally have to say probably
his idea of what a good-looking person
is I'm very lucky that I don't look like
everyone else cuz I tapped into
something like we say you're a walking
fetish I you walk down the street women
look at you and go not all women
unfortunately but some some cross the
street although some are more than
welcomed are they proper moist there is
actual a lot of uh Instagram groups
where for women who just want be added
tattooed men yeah and are you big on you
could be the face of that that's all
think yeah poster boy yeah why not any
sponsorships out there this is still we
yeah but overall I sort I mean it did
blow up quite a lot didn't it it was
sort of very daily mailed yeah was this
when he got his PE neck jump that was a
great wasn't it when she read him his
quotes back I worry that's going to
happen to us one day that was the worst
worst thing he could have ever done
worst thing the thing is I Lawrence you
sat opposite while he said he was
[__] her hairy [__] and you laughed
do you have any reply to that on news
night my dad just sitting at home [__]
sake what has he
become look at that Polo neck that Polo
I do I have actually wor a polo neck
exactly like [__] hell I never want
to say that I've thought about that
before though like what if every cuz
we've done hours upon hours of things
where you say it's not like 10-minute
videos where it's sort of you really are
aware of everything You' said in that
one vid like I just come out with [__]
do you know what I mean so the amount of
things people could quote back to me by
we're this is podcast 21 or something
like even that's 40 hours yeah but who
get I really care less than I've ever
cared in me life now I just me on the
show like any any old
[__] have 200k I love I love the Tweet
the tweet that you got today that said
Filler episodes yeah what questions did
you get on Twitter we a lot of replies
Haven even looked the main one was who
when you said we've got the guest I
thought I often that's quite mean no I
accept it really yeah you've blown up
quite quickly then you've been around
for eight years that must Prett h
I Jeremy packs me yeah that must really
Hur you Boris yeah I get through it yeah
I get through it smiling yeah how how do
you feel when you see someone H come out
of nowhere and then uh go sort of viral
in that cuz like I've I've seen that
with will I remember I message will when
he was on 25 [__] thousand
subscribers I went you're going to get a
million before I do me I can see it
coming you wanted to own that in does it
I've got that I called it yeah in many
ways that's your channel does it ever
bother you especially when they like
Bell ends like that Pro game I lad H it
it doesn't really bother me it depends
on the content so like Steven I've
watched since he was on thousand and
then he's gone past and it's deserved
it's deserved all I do like I I can moan
about [__] content I'm not saying that
my content's not [__] actually mean I
sit in a shed and slag people off I'm
the shittest one yeah we can all
acknowledge
that I actually think that you're like a
really underrated YouTuber thank like I
actually thought myself I just I don't
get why I just can't understand why some
people have like Pro Gamer for example
and then you not getting the views that
someone like that get it just makes no
[__] sense you're quite challenging
in that sense like so you're sort it's
it's a little bit of a stressful
experience to watch your videos whereas
with Pro Gamer put out my banner it's a
stressful bit of a stress a bit of a
stressful exper yeah I want that on a
show real but then we yeah yeah if you
do cut a show real next year um and then
with him it's more just like you you
know what you're getting do you know
what I mean so you can essentially you
can almost switch off for 10 minutes I
feel like when when you challenge like I
do and you do it's sort of you're
running the risk of pissing people off
to the point where they might not watch
your videos anymore because they people
get emotional if you're challenging
their favorite YouTuber the favorite
footballer I I know for a fact there's
people who've really took the Huff with
me when I've had to go at the team even
though the next week I'll be having to
go at the rivals or whatever and it's
not meant to piss anyone off that much
norch yellow is all right is
it yeah sorry about that to the norch
fans um um but yeah it do you have a
worry about maybe if I was just a little
bit more tame I wouldn't have I would be
bigger than what I am you'd have sold
out though wouldn't you that yeah um it
is weird it is one of those worries that
like well cuz you remember Jack's gap
you probably don't do you you're like
what happened to him they're the twins
his dad owns like a big part of the BBC
so he doesn't really need to do fuckle
but um he he asked me if I wanted to do
a collab back in the day he was very
family friendly and I turned it down and
then everyone he did a collab with it
was like the time when Alfie was growing
marus so then there is that part of your
brain that goes if I'd have done that
collab I might have been all right but
then I wouldn't have been making the
same [__] you would you may have been
daily vlogging at this point sort of you
might have gone down a different route
yeah I think that there's definitely a
btle between credibility and growing the
channel and doing this
podcast and doing the podcast I've had
to think to myself all right who do I
want on and how do I want to treat them
as well and because if someone's doing
you a favor you have to appreciate that
as well and say all right for example if
JJ comes on now luckily I just generally
get on with a lad but I'm saying if um a
big YouTuber like PewDiePie was to come
on and I and I genuinely don't really
like I don't dislike PewDiePie but from
what I've seen of him he's not the type
of YouTuber I would sit and watch hours
of um I course I'd have him on the
[__] podcast you'd be doing you a
favor yeah so with us you're doing us
the favor I've had to like think about
it and be like all right thing on
YouTube right now oh true yeah true will
actually said about stepen that you're
the best YouTuber right now in his in
his opinion yeah yeah that's what you
said
but you guys I thought I was annoyed cuz
I was like he not been watching the
holiday football holidays the table and
went for [__] sake no but there is
definitely for people like me and you
how likable am at versus how funny am I
yeah the batttle of not going too far
sometimes because well you yeah you've
hit the nail on the head that is
literally it do do I want to do a video
about popcorn slag off sorry what
popworks four great flavors I love it
genuinely though that made me go out and
buy one flavors that is mental isn't it
that is what was it like uh it was good
it was the apple pie one which is
actually really really nice that is
mental so I'm a direct marketing works
you two have set this up I told you this
the other day I couldn't [__] believe
it they're not paying us me anything
particular so I sort it out moving on i
s it out but on the other hand I think
it's quite a lot of Brands won't work
with me because of the [__] I say but
then you do have that very Niche like
those few brands that like that content
so they will get behind it and because
there's not a lot of YouTubers swearing
a bit edgy I hate the word edgy but the
way say so so they they'll pay they'll
pay more money so if you get the right
Brands the suit and TI is really they
[__] me off to be honest because it's
like this YouTube is is YouTube
initially was supposed to be about real
people making real videos about
themselves and it because it's became
such a cash cow it's about the people
usually at the top are the fakest
[__] [__] you can get making all the
money and pretending like they live the
the Disney life yeah think pissing me
off I mean that that's part of the
marketing of you he shaves his balls
like everyone else whatever do you know
what I mean he does things that are
embarrassing that he might not admit to
you shave your
balls I used I used to sort of keep more
track of it than I do to be honest
probably could do with a the amount of
times I've cut my penis it's just well
apparently apparently V apparently vits
the way forward but they're not paying
so I don't know yet yeah you're my mom
for that as well guys yeah good God
if so smooth smooth as a baby spot him
and he knows what they those feel like
as well doesn't he bloody do [__] me
there's just way too much pedopilia you
YouTube is marketed as something real
doesn't it is real do you know I mean
organic on it's just a bit upsetting
that the the the audience of these big
squeaky clean YouTubers they don't
realize they don't realize they're eight
or nine no when I was eight or n even
then I would have said [__] this
[__] maybe that's just me you are not
the average of I was listening to The
Slim Shady LP at that point so I
probably would have used those exact
words I don't know that many kids who
would have I didn't know the word [__]
until I was 16 it was my first word yeah
I can honestly imagine that yeah [__]
yeah looked at my mom [__] it's probably
why she loves
vodka I'm just like smooth as a baby's
frustrated cuz like I got a tweet last
week from a kid saying that all all the
kids in his year have been talking about
was the KSI podcast and I was like
[__] great like cuz that just makes
you feel good when you hear things like
that and then I'm thinking then who the
[__] watching Alfie Vlogs do you know
what I mean so good it must be the girls
in the year what are they doing thing is
you do know you know I can watch bbc1
but also bbc2 you know what I mean I'm
not sort going oh bbc1 I'm sticking with
it you know I can flick around sure
sometimes I'll pause our podcast just to
make sure there's nothing to that we
left in and sort go away and you know
watch one of these two and be like that
makes me happy again now back to you
know what I mean though I'm just saying
like I just I want the reality of what
YouTube was supposed to be back yeah but
then Alfie would Alfie may make the
argument this is my reality is it isn't
[__] it's not I know a lot of people
that know him and based on that I've
only ever spoke to him once yeah um and
it was so it's probably what birthed
this weird sort of hatred of him like I
just tweeted this was 2011 12 just
tweeted um very very much on point to
what you're saying something about I
hate when YouTubers pretend to love One
Direction just to get the directions on
board sure that was all I put and then I
got a Skype call from him didn't even
know I had him on there come up Alfie
days and then he went um C can you take
your Tweet down please and I was like
sorry what he was playing the the
character of a
farmer take your Tweet down please and
then train the Laur of
fields uh and then I was like it's not
it's not about you he like no but people
are going to think is about me it's like
well it's not my fault mate yeah it's
not my fault and then Casper Lee was in
the room because that's when they live
together and he's like actually Jack I
can't do voice I
stop what
great cly well Alfie does actually like
One Direction so what what's your point
what is your it's not about him then
yeah mugs yeah so it yeah that is a good
point is people do get very pissed off
that's like that can you imagine someone
Skype calling me asking me to take a
tweet
down [__] off you stupid what would you
do what would you do I laugh i' just no
all they would hear is me laughing and
then the call ends and that'll be it and
then I'll be thinking why didn't I Rec
happened that news so yeah yeah can you
believe people are that petty um yeah
actually yeah like quite a few people
are worried about I think quite a few
people are insecure on YouTube because
they're worried someone else is going to
come along and take their spot and the
irony is that YouTube's supposed to be
collaboration some of them should be
because it'll be so easy to recreate
that with a younger better looking kid
for example do you know what I mean yeah
I'm not paranoid about that any time and
but but what about but the YouTube sort
of it it tells you collaborate go and
man collaborate and so many people after
they've collaborated go he's still my
idea you collaborated mate that's whole
point is you're supposed to share ideas
everyone sits in the room and goes it's
my idea to do the penalty Challenge and
you're like you're not the first guy
take a [__] penalty we're not talking
about um oh no no no no penalty challeng
yeah cuz I know we've got friends who do
those you know what we love you all no
some of them are bollocks like genuinely
you know some of them are really bad but
some of them are good some of them
people take better penalties than others
I see what you're saying some of them I
enjoy like Chris MD did a really good
one a few weeks ago where they took the
studs off the boots and I was like
that's really clever yeah yeah you can
tell he puts a lot of he puts some yeah
like you can tell when graft goes into
something when someone goes should we do
a penalty challenge again today Lads
yeah well that's what I think I'd like
about both of these Lads is you can tell
a video isn't just something they've
shut out day like there's no and it
there's no way us do a video like the
same day you think about it and you
upload it the same there's no way that
all happens in one day either of you I
can just tell do you so when you shoot
because you do a lot of different angles
yeah I know you do different angles I
like I like the way you crop the the way
you did that Croc thing the other day
where it said [__] on the sign in
the background was brilliant thank you
but the uh the way that you do it do you
film all One Direction and then all want
I don't mean the band do you feel all
who he loves by the way in case he
offends anyone say that tweet out mate
so in case do you film all one take for
one person and all one take for the
other or will you go okay do your line
I'll do my line yeah no we do it all at
once um so that takes longer to cut
because you got to find your PS there
see so I didn't realize that well of
course if you like if you you can just
lay things back to back I know we we
make so many mistakes it's it's going to
take ages I like the outakes yeah I've
got I've got a lot of outake like Max at
the moment he's getting a lot of
mentions uh he's sort of the brains of
the operation and looks and uh got two
one yeah he did he what did you get a
first but you know that just makes me
look like a smug [__] it's a first in
comedy but do you think the word
comedian gets thrown around a little bit
too much there's there's a few comedians
who I'm not going to name name them I've
met on YouTube and and there was one or
two where I'm like are you a comedian no
it's like Instagram Comedians and
there's other guys who do sort of a
similar thing to what you do about
Instagram stuff you know there's that
whole strain of people who kind of find
someone that's easy to hate and then
sort of goes I'm going to go in on this
guy and it is good you know what I mean
some of them are more observant than
others very observant some people try
and rip you off and they literally just
name the things that that person does
you know what I mean whereas you're a
bit more rainbow poo specific I like
that poo yeah whatever it was unicorn
poo yeah that was it something like that
you know unicorns come out of rainbows
there [__] whatever is it do you I
mean yeah that it does get thrown around
quite a lot doesn't it yeah I know got a
degree in it yeah I know I mean yeah is
Ricky ja got a degree no I didn't even
say comedy there
over panicked but no it's like I know
comedy subjective but there's levels and
I I see people like before I started I
used to see some people on Facebook and
they just get a girl with big tits in
Parton my language there for my mom
who's watching you still haven't said
[__] by the way saving it with big tits
and a a sweet [__] so true [__] me and
and and they rely on that to get to get
people to watch the video on Facebook
and it's awful content and I just
thought it's like Woody and kiny a
comedy J oh God you're like dick and dut
with an extra chromosone and it's awful
it really is Woody and
kleiny and it it's just terrible would
you ever do anything they did SL
football actually before SL football
genuinely Woody and kiny with the first
thing on SL
football you've Advanced they've taken
the videos down I mean that channel has
gone from strength they had Lacy bangard
on oh exactly there you go I mean You'
pretty much nailed that who's Lacy
bangard I think I don't remember who she
was I just remember she went on uh I
think she was maybe on Big Brother or
something and she came on and uh and
they're both sitting there today got
Lacy
bangard um it's my real
name um it's and then she they went what
are you doing Lacy with your time now
well I'm uh I'm training for cycling
from Paris to London no brilliant Lacy
anything else you do yeah I've got a
range of condoms we'll uh we'll skirt
over that no go in on that you guys are
not pmen like you need to go in on that
bit Yeah didn't even follow up on it
bang hard condoms well this is the type
of people I've got to choose from when
trying to get a girl on the podcast you
know what I mean no wonder haven't had
you just have an intelligent woman
on don't say the how to
find I can just sometimes now the thing
is wants to come out
at his M it's like theia sitting over
there in that
red so yeah um you got some more tweets
just to stop yourself I like sort of one
thing I like about your videos is the
way you sort of play this like pompous
arrogant little bastard yeah yeah yeah
what are you dra and then you turn the
camera on I I I'd like you to do more
like that if I if I could see you do
like just as a te maybe vlogers vlogers
him like sort of like a day in the life
of yeah that would be I would like it's
just
it's like I've always been like that's
my go-to sort
of like you know insulting people being
obnoxious and it's of course like if you
watch Partridge and like Brent you're
going to get it really reminded me of
partridge in particular like a young
Partridge I've been called that before
I'd seen Partridge which I realized is
an insult like when you're 14 in school
not really well if you're trying to be
funny though it's it's a Bel guess
compliment isn't it I suppose those guys
did sort of shape a generation of men
didn't they you know a lot of people I
think just it sort of became part of
their character to be that sort and it's
quite an English character as well sort
of be that kind of slightly emasculated
man's kind of over compensating over
compensating a bit of a loser sometimes
kind of doesn't have very much luck with
the women you know I'm not targeting um
you know but like that is that's that's
something that's very British British
character there yeah yeah you do that
quite well it's quite well played yeah
well it's you know it's it's a it's a
challenge to you're one of the most
requested people we've had on really
Jack I mean Jack was requested as well
but like you've got like a whatever
you in all just said though you've got
like a a really hardcore following going
on at the moment it's surprising yeah
because how much he's will to thank for
that well you know he charges me quite a
bit each week for the
tweets he puts that jaw to
work um but yeah it's uh I I really like
the audience cuz it's not like the
typical sort of morons you get with some
other
people and it's it's people that like
appreciate comedy like they quote stuff
and they write out what they like and
you can see they pick out jokes and
stuff that that I think of and they
notice it it's like I like the grandma
and the iPad joke by the way thank that
was a quality one little quiet aside to
the best ones for me um I did that once
and uh it the worst gig ever did it was
a Christmas du in January and I uh a
year ago do you want to repeat the joke
so people get it um what is it oh I'm
talking about old people in technology
and I say uh you know uh Manan thought
oh God I can't even think of it oh yeah
I got Manan got a A Selfie Stick no man
got oh this is
awful stage this is very similar to his
actual stand up hold on guys yeah people
are going I love that nervous [__] he
that nervous act yeah got Selfie Stick
Of Christmas yeah um something thought
was a
dildo this is awful that's the joke
isn't it yes B basically you could do it
better than me she was she was something
along the lines of um yeah minan thought
the M thought was a dildo we won't be
getting those photos developed yeah
that's it yeah Jesus Ste we got there in
the end ruined it a Butch of digital
camer if you're seeing Steven for the
first time on this podcast trust me his
channel is way better than
what you're seeing here is a shamble
it's a shell of a
man I'm not a painful either no that is
actually no that is not convicted anyway
not yet you're only guilty if you get
caught exactly so [__] it and if you
stay quiet Jonathan that is bad even for
me Jesus we've got Twitter questions
yeah loads of them well actually not
that not about two so the top one who
yeah that came in quite a lot who who
Jack um worst thing you've ever had to
tell someone that you've done confession
you ever confessed anything that was
really hi Alfie I've done I've done a
video about you manate yeah you you know
you told us to delete that tweet yeah I
haven't but I have done a video about
you I'm still [__] on you from a
distance I don't know you ever like had
to come clean about anything there were
girl or anything like that you said you
split up with that girl what happened
with her I mean sort of aligned yourself
with our early do awful or did it just
sort of Peter out got a new girlfriend
now so do you in a relationship long
been gone two years next week a long
time is that Valentine's Day yeah he
loves this one I've learn my [__]
lesson he loves this one even if it was
3 weeks in fresh you love her probably
yeah I'm going to go with
yes I don't know I don't know I'm quite
an upfront person so I don't really get
what what what would you say it's like
for her to be in a relationship with
you the boss that you you about all of
it she knew me before she knew my
YouTube channel before wow yeah was that
how you met sort of thing or she came up
to me in a club and said I like your
videos hello I mean that for you must
have thought tell you what sorted let's
that's a we're in to talk to us
brilliant yeah and then he said join the
CU join the it was simil to that KSI
situation where he went this is my
bouncer take her away I went photo
autograph take
your yeah n yeah she she's all right
she's all right she's good and CAU have
you have you got her a gift for
Valentine's Day uh yes this probably
won't be out before then so you can tell
what it is if you just a standard just
taking it just taking it to B condoms
yes it nice hotel that 10 of five taking
it to the in
she five
things this
position or was it this one that's a
good he's going he's ring off mentally
he's writing all this down well the
thing is when when we first started this
it was Lawrence's mission to sort of
make me a better person I guess but it's
just the opposite made him a worse
person especially off camera he's a
massive [__] now off camera he's you are
more of a an insatiable C some people
say bang on bang on bang on yeah that
was your experience 5,000 SP
coins he's had that one waiting for you
I guess
last um what about you so you haven't
got a valentine no unless Babs gets back
in touch on on Tinder it's going to be a
lonely
one do you try and use any of your lines
on on Tinder what Manny on
them that is what you did that works on
L Manny on the map what is that even
referencing I don't know it's a it's a
Grime MC called Bugsy Malone and I
watched him and he said Manny on the map
a lot so I thought when I do stormy cuz
of been man Chester I just say man on
the map and then I panicked and said it
again and that's become a catchphrase
now it's like people like kids see me in
the street and go PE don't now they go
money on the
M he's
back not again it's ni when you say
something on YouTube and people take it
because event it's something you can't
escape yeah yeah like I said does my
drink and offend you like and I didn't
say for 2 years and I still get people
like saying it yeah we should have put
that on a t-shirt by now that's we would
have made way more money someone did
yeah well I'll talk about that later um
and then I guess though it is quite hard
also because as a comedian I guess you
sort of have to not every woman wants to
be with a comedian yeah you know what I
mean by that do you feel like um your M
has sort of like had to suffer for your
art in any way I know you've had her in
a couple of videos haven't you I I do
yeah like I do make a lot of jokes when
it's just me and her and she's just like
she finds me funny but sometimes it's
like I'm not in the mood yeah or I'll do
a joke that I was supposed to do one of
my mates and then it's like do this
really weird joke it's not funny in any
way unless you're me but I basically
just go up to my mates and I'll be like
one of these days I'm going to [__]
smash it I did it to my girlfriend once
did not go down very well do you feel
like we were talking to JJ that's not
even a joke we were talking to JJ and he
was like I'm not sure I should have had
I mean I know it's different cuz that
video he did with his girlfriend got
like 30 [__] million views but still
you you're still going to be well
recognized and that were you a bit
worried about putting her in the videos
If I Was A looker and people subscribed
to me cuz they thought he's fit then I
probably wouldn't have mentioned that
had a girlfriend because then all the
girls unsubscribed but they're not
subscribed for that reason anyway so
honestly just enough chance I've done
quite well look at this yeah yeah
jealous I always say laughter can get
any woman's Nick most women's Nick as
off that's something also something Jack
repeats multiple
times that's actually his main pulling
when she tells me no o listen laughter
get get them do you laugh legally
binding you ever done anything you
regret um yeah you've had to like come
clean to anyone oh um there's one but
it's really morally wrong and involves
my deceased Granddad so we'll go into
that one
today I didn't kill him by the way just
in case get that pinned on me I think no
um you can't that got cleared in court
so can't get us on that one I don't no
I've not done anything that bad I'm
quite a good boy you do look
like great story I think I'm fine the
scoop another one um keemstar's watching
on for [__] sake nothing on this one
YouTube or non YouTube inspiration when
not jaice was the man anyone um yeah uh
Steve koug Rick but in terms of standup
it' be probably the main one would be
Kevin Bridges I think yeah he's really
good
I met him once and he was just so down
to do you want to do more standup in the
future are you are you thinking more
sketch more TV prefer I prefer sort of
yeah sketches in terms of like the
nerves and stuff it's just yeah I've
doing a bit of public speaking lately um
which s of I turned it into standup to
be honest cuz I thought it's easier just
to make jokes than actually give people
valuable information and it can get
quite the first one by the by the second
time and the third time I was
comfortable as F but the first one was
was a little bit like [__] hell like
a lot of people looking at us and I
didn't think I would be nervous but I
was a tiny bit nervous for that yeah
it's it's all like the the worst thing
for me is like that's why I have so many
jokes I think well try to anyway in
sketches and stuff it's because I hate
the sound of silence um just like jump
Cuts as well ideal you know but the
thing is you're going to do jump cuts
too you sort of you have to sketch and
sort of script out your stuff yeah guess
ask Stephen how he comes up with all of
his ideas skits oh I I do a lot of
ketamin guys it's it's cheap
it's you would know it's not cheap isn't
it no I've been sold the wrong stuff
yeah um did they just come to you or
like the chicking
coners I wonder how I can make oh there
we go yeah I like yeah I base it on a
lot of sort of uh things to say in in
just in the media so it's it's yeah it's
just things I've watched and things are
like um things that can make jokes the
pedopile hunter um I just thought that's
a funny I got contacted by two legit ped
Hunters who wanted to come on and
promote what they're doing on that but
I'm like what do I want to be it's a
YouTube channel yeah yeah but I was a
they've got like two 5sec videos of them
going up to a pedo with a camera in his
face I don't even know if it was a legit
pedo I'm like I yeah I don't know what
the [__] going on I'm trying to make a
vlog uh yeah that was a bit weird so
didn't yes fair enough I was cuz I'm
kind of interested in I'm obviously
interested in vigilantism it's funny
that like Vigilant there's something
about a vigilante that's like you know
they're The Outsider do you know like
Batman's the Vigilante everyone wants to
be but then when vigilante I always
think of um Freddy Got Fingered sure I'm
a vigilante yeah have you ever seen
Freddy got
finger but but it's the name of one of
the P it really is like one no but it is
seriously [__] funny though isn't it
yeah but I mean but I was never it was
one of those ones as a kid I wanted to
watch it and my mom was like you're not
watching it the word fingered is
probably what put her off that that
title is from his dad finger in him so
oh is it okay watch he didn't actually
get fingered but it's the illusion
probably on Netflix spoilers if anyone
out there hasn't seen it just [__]
watch it I I'll make sure I do yeah I
love when you recommend
shows daddy would you like
some that clip on the piano or something
yeah the backwards man the backwards man
you keep they've not seen I'm sorry but
I've gone now I'm in Freddy Got Fingered
Mode God
yeah so she has a question for you
dealing with getting older what if
YouTube doesn't work out I mean they've
got the subscribers now they're probably
going to be fine but let's just say for
whatever reason Scandal hits people
startop watching Lads oh I'm going to
tap into Vimeo uh no I think
I think it's uh I don't know like I did
an office job once and it was literally
like three days a week and I just I just
fell apart I love how you assume that
you just be straight back to an office
like that no one in the BBC or someone
would
go um so it' be yeah I I I don't know if
I don't enjoy doing something then I
just won't do it some of the most
hilarious reports people ever guys I
need you you find that YouTubers in
particular tend to be that kind of
person who like who basically took a
risk went ah [__] real life I want to
try and do this and if it doesn't work
I'd rather have tried to do something
that was a pipe dream than just go and
deal with reality now and if I have to
deal with reality later then so be but
I'm going to give it a good [__] go
of doing like thisll no plan B though
really on you go into this really is I
mean there you can obious do an office
thing but there's the pl I'll be all
right because as you know I'm sitting on
50,000 Spar coins so good point I am
fine for
life no I don't know yeah I'll do a bit
try I think if YouTube went then I'd
kind of have to like stop being a botler
and actually try some standup comedy I
think the sitcom as well so hopefully
that is is that about based around
something you know like very much so
yeah very much so sitting on the couch
playing FIFA should be good looking
forward to that yeah no yeah no um who
knows I'm excited to watch that I'm
excited to one they see your ultimate
demise when you have to pull that if you
need any actors um I'm pretty good at
acting some uh I got approached recently
to be a hard man in a football film so
are you taking that the journey starts
now you taking that I may do yeah why
you good actor well I I can I reckon you
are definitely like he definitely puts
in a performance but then there are
times where you worry he's quite method
so you know if he's tired on camera
he'll very often be tired off camera you
know on camera yeah ex he weaves it in
yeah Milan [__] Milan [__] is what he
said we we worked it all in though it
came up well in the end I'm really tired
I want to kill you um hilarious if you
had to do a regular job and you weren't
allowed to do this [__] that we're
doing right now I know mine straight
away I used to work in Bella Italia I
actually liked it yeah and it was
halfway through my YouTube journey I was
already I was making good money from
YouTube and then my cousin was assistant
manager of Bella and he went you on a
job I went can do did you like the food
y Champion yep eight months I did that I
loved it I like Italian food I'm
actually eaten there it's nice there
have you what you get Italian U I
usually I usually go with prawns if
people have watched the Milan video and
if you haven't what the [__] are you
doing with your life Mars prawns or a
good one garlic prawns and uh just I
prefer I've realized lately if you go in
Italian you should try and go pasta
rather than steaks I used to always get
staks I've had quite a few bad steaks in
Italians lately and I thought just stick
with what they are good at what they do
p Gamboni Gamboni my favorite man
manager what you do getting a steak at
[__] Italian I just love stakes in
general so if there's a steak available
I usually say it but actually what I've
started doing is I'll get a starter I'll
get a a spaghetti and then I'll also get
a steak just on off chance that the
steak is quality there it's a gamble you
take um so should we doal favorite steak
favorite steak I like a fet steak okay
but um I mean sirine torn whatever's
gone really I will the first time we
ever went to discuss this podcast bought
me a a massive steak do you remember we
had that big steak I remember it well
because at the time you were on the
phone trying to fix your other stupid
podcast and uh I was like yeah don't
worry about this one it's just going to
be 10 times better ultimately that guy
did bottom us out in the end so it was a
bit of a waste of a a night really well
yeah but at least you had a nice [__]
fat STI on my bank account yeah that was
the last time you got any money out of
me wasn't it quite true is your surname
cast or is that just I wish it was yeah
yeah no it is McKenna
oh yeah Lawrence yeah oh he still hasn't
said [__] yet say for this
CT do it on camera rolling it's rolling
mate oh crumbs
right who says crumbs crumb [__] hell
it you guys might not thec if you have
seen the podcast we answer problems
emails uh TR problems gmail.com yeah I'm
always here anyway uh a few weeks ago we
did a uh an an email about a guy with
KSI and quite a few people got offended
by it uh cuz the guy said every time I
introduced myself to someone uh people
think I'm a terrorist and we made some
jokes about it we make jokes on this if
you haven't realized near two hours into
the podcast we're not always being
serious did the jokes bomb or they do uh
it's good one of the issues with the
jokes was that uh we we apparently made
jokes about and I think really people
don't tend to get sort of sarcasm and
some people just take it very seriously
and that's the problem is that we're
there being sarcastic and they go this
would be offensive to terrorists you
know who should we piss off
yeah if is is all listening I just want
to say I've got no problem with you at
all just leave my house alone yeah I
also think though Isis did tune in at
some point go this is Extreme isn't
it um we'd never treat women like
that anyway um yeah it didn't go well uh
so sorry to any um hardcore extremists
out there that we offended uh we really
are apologetic about that um turns out
joking about strapping a bomb on your
body isn't
funny well you know some people can pull
it
off not in time
apparently and then there's another one
a religious followup there was a guy who
wrote to us from Salt Lake City
beautiful place in I remember that one
the moment yeah now I've got for a good
Mormon girl yeah and I said just pretend
to be Mormon and that's the way forward
see this is how much I care about you
[__] [__] remember your problems and
everything sure don't know if you guys
remember I do about that religious girls
email I sent a few weeks back well I
ended up sneaking out of my house and
going to one of the most Mormon girls in
my school what makes it the most how do
you is there a level of Mormon
yeah the biggest
Mormon like subscribers like how many
how many Mormon followers does she have
do you know what I mean that's such a
good line I love did people in in Utah
going B out of the be such a good line
um anyway he went to her house while I
was inside of her she screamed very loud
that got there was no in between yeah
literally it goes from oh yeah I went
there oh and then I was inside her
screamed very loud this well maybe was
this consensual or what you know what I
mean oh no yeah that's a good point
actually he doesn't confirm that however
dad walked in because of his work
schedule he worked 400 p.m. to 4:00 a.m.
and he walked in while we were banging
so I leave the girl or do something it's
kind of a follow-up problem uh so he's
sort of been found out for having sex
M I'll let the guests take the floor
yeah you guys take the floor so I'm
confused so the dad walked in whilst he
having a wild time yeah this guy's big
problem was that he couldn't find any
local women because he lives in Utah who
are willing to have sex okay because
they're all quite
religious we and jordy's advice was go
and find you know pretend to be a bit of
a Mormon and go over and find one okay
so he's not a Mormon I mean I think he
sort of on the SC he's on the Spectrum
you know you know he's officially a mman
but he's not he doesn't believe the
[__] yeah not that it is [__]
you're right actually I don't think many
Mormon do do the Teran he he's the only
one we've gotten he knows it's [__]
so it's fighting I'd imagine there's
quite a few [__] who listen to this so
so sure surely he's got nothing to worry
about then because it's the dad that
should be having to go with the daughter
he he's out I mean it seems although he
what his problem was that he couldn't
find anyone else to have sex with he's
found a girl to have sex with but now
what do they do I mean this is the issue
is you know he's been found out he wants
repeat I guess yeah I mean once you've
been you know you sort of just can he
bring her around to his place or maybe
she can give him the bus or something
this is it yeah what would you how does
he play it with the dad though that's
the thing as well cuz cuz you know those
dads they've all got guns in America
lots of
guns City and if he catches him in there
again may get a bullet in his ass yeah
you've got way up the options haven't
you is it worth it is it worth a would
you take a bullet for for sex would you
bust a nut to kapper to bust a c bust
there we go yeah would you bust in her
ass to get a cat bust in
yours I mean I he would take theis would
all the time be like B the end of the
gun I've had this happen before like
sort of um I was um having sex with a
girl um and her dad sort of s us through
the window sort of thing he was in the
Marines and that and uh he's a pretty
like hard lad like sort of thing and I
got on really well with
him and he came and joined in yeah um no
uh yeah and I had like a really good
Bond and good friendship with him yeah
after that or pre pre pre come and yeah
and it just never recovered from that
what did you reference it or did he
mention it when he walked through the
door cuz could see you through the
window yeah he when he walked through
the door he he could look me in the eye
and you pretty much never did ever again
yeah cuz um I was
um yeah I was it wasn't like it was just
normal sex either though it was pretty
what was it sort of gymnastics I what
was it um I was eating her ass at the
time
Fu sort of could you not have just been
giving her like a rectile exam or
something just I'm just taking a
Gynecology so just Practice What You
Preach oral gynecology
yeah I tore it up anyway did be tongue
yeah I mean I asked too many questions
go for
it the next one's entitled clingy okay
great hey Jordi Lawrence and guest says
guests guest we are one uh got a bit of
a dilemma I could use your help with no
[__] my friend I've known for five years
let's call her Sally had a crush has a
crush on me and has asked me to go to
Senor prom with her the only problem is
I find her annoying and too clingy she's
my friend but I see her as more of a
younger sister than anything else I've
dropped many hints to her that I'm not
interested my dilemma is that her best
friend who who she introduced me to her
best friend the girl I like and are
pretty close with and she's just an all
round amazing girl I don't know what to
do I don't want to ruin any friendships
because Sally and her best uh sorry
between Sally and her best friend but I
don't like Sally next one you don't you
don't think that's an issue no
the thing
is friendships and that [__] aren no
especially at that age we we all know
that like don't worry about keeping
girls happy and friends and all that
crap at that age run through them mate
if she's if she's
clingy girls and this is a fact girls
who are clingy will do anything like
they are the ones who do the freakiest
[__] you can think whatever you're into
a clingy girl is so desperate to keep
you happy they'll do anything so so and
another thing is if you don't think
she's that good looking now what's
senior prom how old's that 16 17 she
she'll get better she probably she'll
probably get better I think it was
always like the like the average or
subpar looking girls that are hotter now
and then back schore the hotter ones are
like they decline they balloon yeah they
take it granted yeah they take it for
granted and Metabolism slows down and
when they hit 25 bang I seen my first
ever girlfriend today actually um I
haven't seen that in years and I was at
the train station and I was having a
chat I was having a chat with someone
giving it the old are you the true
Jordie thing big fan of you actually
like you and uh she walked sort of past
and I was like [__] hell like you
know you have that moment where but your
face gives nothing away but your brain's
going [__] hell I me I just kept
there like yeah you're all right and
just like but like I know for a fact
that she normally sort of makes a little
bit of effort with herself and she'll
have makeup on she look she she hasn't
let herself go that much great but
that's what you're looking for really
isn't the point I'm making is she looked
dog rough that day and I was one of
those where I know she'll think [__]
great day not to wear any [__] make
she'll be she'll be cuz I was looking
like decent you see what you know I look
I always look decent I don't need makeup
I'm a man but she um she really looked
bad um sure and I just felt a bit sorry
for her really afterwards sure maybe she
was trying to put you off maybe went I
think she was might have been meeting a
block or something like that and I mean
that's awkward for her as well cuz
obviously she's peaked is what you're
saying
substandard are you I don't know
girlfriend pictures is the title of the
next one hey Jordi Lawrence and guests
you read them over my shoulder you know
it says guest one of my mates has a
girlfriend who's really hot let's call
her Ashley like 10 out of 10 while my
friend was on
holiday the sentence structure in this
is pretty I mean you've seen that yeah I
was talking to were on a video chat and
my best friend was there too we were
talking and she then started stripping
for us neither of us stopped her because
of how hot it
was I took screenshots but I don't know
if I should show the friend or not
because it might ruin the friendship and
they seem to really like each other PS
Lawrence over Jordy anyway we need to
see the screenshots really to be able to
forge an opinion on them next week yeah
and then we can then we can go into it
but I don't quite understand what
happened there because he says the best
friend was also there there was another
friend I think the other bit so the
original friend who's with her isn't
there for the strip sh he's with one of
his other mates yeah wow what kind of
girl who really likes a boy is stripping
for his mates that's mental that is
mental slug Yeah
well yeah he was with you for a little
while slug none of us are with those
comments you've seen his videos he's
just as bad he doesn't say so do say so
do you not not really you say [__] a lot
that two
[__] slag two [__] don't make a slag
all right can that be the
title try to keep C now because it stops
you from uh geted does it it's I've had
a real deal with these titles in the
past you know yeah you had a great deal
with it well Samy azri [__] this over
didn't it yet again bloody bloody [__]
BL he
is hey jordian Lawrence [__] you too I'm
16 and I live in a highly religious area
where Trump is generally loved gay
um it's the the email is entitled gay
Instagram that's why I'm let go uh a guy
I really like talked uh talking and
hanging out with hanging out of no
sorry but isn't one of isn't one of my
mates has a secret Instagram where he
posts topless pictures and a bit more
with hashtags such as # gay # gay life
and a bit
more instead of detail in I won stop
there uh he used a fake name genius and
once it started to get leaked around the
school he deleted the account but
certain people I really don't trust have
screenshots and I'm afraid they'll leak
them so I into a
part yeah it does seem like a lot of
people in Utah listen to this they're
very sexually Sur press uh he isn't
allowed to be gay by the way uh he would
practically get disowned if he came out
the dude's really nice to everyone and I
like him so my question is should I tell
him that I know about it and that I
fully support him and uh I'm here for
him or should I not mess with what's not
my business well he's he he said he's
posted topless photos yeah nothing about
that is gay you wouldn't look at a
topless blo and go gay but he did he did
hashtag them gay gay life is there any
way of saying that maybe it was someone
who got the photos from him and then set
a fake profile the blackmail there we go
it was of it it wasn't verified so the
people with the screenshots I mean I'm
still not verified on Twitter now mate
so neither am I everything's denable
that Twitter account might still be none
of us are not me that might not be me
still to this day Blue Tick means
nothing that doesn't it to some people
it means a lot maybe to you it means
something because I imagine a lot of
people are ripping off your content
maybe with you and you as well no but
you know there are people out there with
three 400 followers who have got that
blue tick and you just
think degrades the overall use of the
Blue Tick doesn't it Jamie vard's look
alike has got a Blue Tick a man that
looks like someone else is verified for
that
re he really had that he had he had a
good 15 minutes of fil didn't he he has
the Blue Tick forever though doesn't
nice swet lasted yeah famous for 10
minutes a Blue Tick lasts forever yeah
till Instagram is gone and Twitter's
dead loneliness hiball had him on by the
way so definitely upgraded again then hi
Jordy my name is not
Dean just a roll of thumb in life just
tell people your name is not Dean before
you go anywhere but call me that anyway
oh that's okay uh I'm 17 and currently
in college and have a love uh have a
love life about as active as this one's
terrible I didn't read ahead as active
as am Frank's drum kit
I'm Frank's drum kit [__] and my DMs are
about as dry as the Sahara I'm Frank's
drum kit that is very that is a very
good that's a very good reference though
very funny refence that one heard it but
hav you well just now uh I haven't had a
girlfriend ever and it's getting to the
point where I want to I want that to
change stop emailing in [__] podcast
Loser yeah uh
I'm however I'm too scared to go sliding
into a girl DMS as I'm too concerned
that they think of uh that they what
they think of me and I'm worried about
rejection oh [__] hell it's every
[__] email man every bastard email is
about rejection [__]
me you don't throw your [__] rod in
the [__] River you're never going to
catch
note and that's not referencing STI or
anything you know about his company now
yeah that's Industries yeah it's all
that needs to be said I think one all
all young Lads just need to pluck up
some bassard confidence and have a
[__] go do you know what I mean how
do you walk up to a girl what do you
what do you do um let's play it let's
getting the camera that's actually
genius that's that's very good yeah yeah
yeah so I'm also verified on Twitter oh
sorry
darling and make sure you get the whole
environment behind you Al D style let's
role play it now okay uh you're going to
approach who do you want to be the woman
which woman do you want to approach
you're the approach me or you're the
woman and I'm sort of his wing man okay
great and then you can direct the scene
okay where are where are we what's where
are we you are in
nandos for a SC no 8-year-old got in
nandos we all know that yeah
yeah but we're just keeping them away
from children just to clarify just to
keep them away from
children okay you ready he really seems
like he's taking this gu he look how
nervous he's got now he's so nervous he
looks he looks that stressed out it's as
if he's watching one of his
videos [__] stressful experience I love
how you said that it's quite stressful
watching your content I think stressful
cuz I think wow this guy's miles ahead
of me what am I going to do to catch up
[__] got a [__] shed with me and you
were sort of drinking beers by the bar
hey wait wait wait I'm I'm the director
Waters all
right I thought I could be pouring some
sort of mild like you're really hot like
if you're [__] fit ass
character and you're lemon and Herb very
hot medium go my name's not Dean by the
way so
uh so yeah yeah knocked in yeah so uh
yeah look at her she's a bit of all
right isn't she she's not bad you know
I'd say uh she's Perry Perry hot that's
uh I like that we're Nando do yeah good
reference point she's she's set at the
same table so it looks pretty good she's
coming over she's coming over you've
just found out she actually works here
and she's been cleaning the tables can I
can I take this one yeah but it's fire
away you need a honey yeah you got me
got
me ex excuse me sweet
cheeks sorry
what um excuse me
um Ashley Jane excuse me Jane Jane is
she
[Music]
40 sure yeah I've literally never met a
woman under the edge of 4 called Jane
called Jan yeah sure brexits hit me
hard yeah hey hey Jan me and uh Marcus
me and my P Marcus over here we we're
just talking about you um don't get
self-conscious okay it was all lovely
stuff um I am feeling a bit
self-conscious now do you I sorry I've
got to get back to work do you mind if I
just before you go just for you um maybe
your number
Jane I I don't have a mobile phone I'm
sorry I no you know your know by heart
yeah Jane come on don't tell me what I
do and don't know right it's men like
you that make me sick both of you and
then and then you realize that you two
used to be in a long-term relationship
oh [__]
Marcus it's me Jane How Could You Forget
Me we spent you've piled on so much weit
no but we spent the best years of our
life together how could you forget all
of this this is I haven't piled on that
much weight it's not a it's not that
I've got an can I just say even in a
role play in which Steven is meant to
pull a girl he's been
rejected this is this is my friend he's
not Dean oh you are gay then no he's my
friend um and he's interested in you and
I thought now that sort of I piled on
the way and I'm probably not your type
anymore maybe sloppy seconds but thanks
maybe you two could oh then you find out
he's got loads of subscribers on the
internet he's have I seen somewhere he's
big on YouTube
um have you ever seen uh Alfie day Vlogs
yeah I play his dog I love Alfie oh my
God you're Nala that's it do the eyes
that's perfect you're allergic to dogs
though really badly it makes you swell
up so in the wrong places so do you
remember Jin you you don't actually like
dogs all that much cuz you hate them you
hate them you're quite abusive to
animals yeah remember that the RS he
actually hit
him the rspc actually got you on the
list so yeah but I work at Nando now
yeah so how's that working out for you
really well actually thank you good you
get to play with an going for you yeah
you like killing the chicken do you do
the chicken killing yourself sometimes
yeah it's more satisfying than ringing
whatever you've got right and scene
brilliant here we go up there no there's
no tutorial in there you completely non
outout as they say I always do that yeah
it's go
to you got a line Jack did you how did
you pull your
current
no she she came to him didn't she in the
club she said what club was it in the
club club of norch weather spoons it
yeah yeah and uh good you had a good
chat did you were you instantly
captivated by her I thought she was nice
yeah yeah great then my mate spoke to
her all night and then at the end of the
night she came over and went just been
Ching to your friend yeah but just been
humoring him yeah oh should we go so he
tried his look and she he tried and then
I it was one of those nights where you
know I'm just not really feeling it
tonight I'm Sheen Vlog she thought I
don't want to get with you let's go
exactly it yeah so I just let him do
what he wanted to do but nothing
happened and then at the end she was
like he's annoying me can I go with you
I do quite like that Jo's Vlogs I do as
well yeah he's quite upbeat I like that
about him I've never watched one really
I know he's got a book out like but I
mean who hasn't these days true not you
from me
true imagine the [__] stor if I did a
book can you imagine what a [__] St what
would happen what would you do what
would you put in the book I know but i'
I slag them off in every video I don't
think there's any room for me to ever do
one unless I did it so ironically that
it was that books owner would certainly
get interesting definitely what would
what would you do if if he turned up
sort of can you delete that book
please Casper Le he does actually write
books one of those are show you're away
uh anyway loneliness he's very lonely we
do one more sure no more advice for him
you really do skirt over people now I
just think D needs to stop messing
around his name's not Dane yeah no he's
he's he's ruined that for me he not not
de he's put the phrase sliding into a
girl's DMS he's being a dick sure yeah
is trying to be casual no you can't say
that unless it's ironic though yeah you
can't he actually says it yeah yeah sure
so don't slide into a girls DMS maybe
start a YouTube channel yeah start a
YouTube channel and just hope that
somebody recognizes you
you actually have you ever had like a DM
yet of a girl's tit on like none of them
have come on you nothing I attract quite
a young audience with the ladies you on
Snapchat yes but any luck on I don't
have it so they can't get to me
honestly get to me they can't get to me
I won't let them
tit no thank you do you leave your I
don't but you've not had a
single flirty DM nothing I've had flirty
DMS yeah but I've not had a a tip no but
you
you've he was drunk so but you've so so
the opportunity has presented itself and
You' sort of yeah you haven't going in
for the kill no oh not on a DM come on
Steven what kind of YouTuber are you
sort your [__] [__] out that's part
of it when the opportunity arises I'm
not a Jo you know he's a player he can
do what he wants Joe really can do what
he wants Joe could do whatever he wants
he [__] what he wants yeah I have that
confirmed
by Joe i' I've heard stories by from Jo
from Joe he just Rings us up and tells
us what he's being up there you'll never
guess what I'm going to start recording
those Skype calls I tell you right those
will be worth a lot of delete that
tweet after Sports is this one's title
it says hello jordian Lawrence and
potential guest we could be guests one
day hello from America I'm a 24 year old
guy that recently finished college and
played baseball for my University
throughout my time there I've been
playing all my life and I've been
finding life more and more difficult
every day because I can't play anymore
baseball offer that outlet for me to get
rid of the frustrations that we've given
that we're given by maintaining my
schooling social life Etc do you guys
have any advice for dealing with life
after Sports why can't he play anymore I
don't know maybe it's an injury maybe
he's you know maybe he's graduated and
he can't it's a hard one that It's
Tricky cuz you're limited by physical
boundaries you can't just nothing we say
like just well could he uh could he
maybe sort of play another kind of sport
like maybe if he can't worst case
scenario is go to the gym and that's
there all was badon but we don't know
what's we don't know what's happened
though he could be paralyzed from the
next down even then then how how has he
written the email NBA 2K you know I just
think he's finished college and he's
stopped with the sports team not at the
same level but maybe has he got an
injury has he actually no he's not
specified he's not specified Bon mashing
[__] mashing [__] uh it's a it's a great
sport you know just get down to your
local Club it's big in wherever he is
America yeah they love it there and uh
yeah to be fair baseball doesn't require
that much physical activity does it do
round does round round us was always
sort of our version of I'm used to like
the metal the metal shiny metal bats
smack them and I used to think I'd love
to hit someone with one of these one day
did you ever no annoying really did want
to mainly the teachers yeah but that was
still to come still time cricket bats
were good as well Crick really if you
get hit in I tell you what especially if
you've got [__] 22 stone and a Jordi
C swing in it imagine that imagine what
I could do with someone's skull with one
of them there's a video yeah I wonder
cuz that you know how they got the hot
knife and all that [__] how about we
just have 100 m hour cricket bat and
just turn that into the next thing there
we go just [__] nuts melons we'll we'll
start with fruit we'll work my way along
and then just get like uh an Alfie de's
book whatever just hit things with it
then Alie days we'll get Alie days skull
whatever we'll go through the motions
aggressive that would go viral it would
it
would how does that man Garner so much
hate he's all right he's all right I
think we all know that he's probably
he's probably not the thing is he's not
as [__] as other people are because he
hiding so much I think it makes me
dislike him that's all sure is it a
Steve Bannon situation anyway um yeah is
it Hillary Clinton is that it is that
the end of the podcast is that I mean if
you want is there anything else you want
to ask from The Lads what's in the
future for you guys you know where are
you taking it that's a good thing ideal
10 years time where is Jack
mate still doing the same [__] sure yeah
Steven I think that's a good answer
because it means you're content with
where you are now of just bigger and
better a a lot of YouTubers get into
it we will and by then we' have played
four games so uh schedule
is uh no a lot of YouTubers go into it
and they try and become presenters or
comedians but now Comedians and
presenters have starting YouTube
channels cuz it's so hard to get jobs
and then they're thinking that looks
easy enough I'll do that and then you
fall flat on the [__] do you know what
it is I'd love to see a lot of these
presenters and comedian
actually get into YouTube I'd like to
see the TV presenters fall flat on their
[__] face as well some do I mean some
do uh some comedians have got there was
a comedian not long ago Rob Becket that
started his
own they're not bad they're fine you
know but they're not uh is a bit it
exposes how average they are yeah no I
think it just sort of shows maybe I just
think it also just sort of shows how
some people go you could cash in on this
and I guess it doesn't show that same
passion like he's not getting into it
cuz he goes I love FIFA you know and
yeah soon to make some cush and it's
obvious another what about you two 10
years well just we'll do Steven first
Ste do you the Young Gun um I don't know
I just want to be doing comedy in some
form my dream like I've always had in my
head to be like one of the best in the
world at comedy so what about like like
a series like so you you you develop a
character and then you a little bit like
bit insulting to what he's done so far
no but I'm a good character have some
money behind you and actually be able to
make yeah a proper office type series
for example yeah I'd love to to have the
opportunity like to do something like
that because at the moment it's filming
outdoors in a park just making the best
of what we've got so that's great though
isn't it it is but having a budget would
be it was like when when we did the
football holiday we actually had some
cash to [__] throw at something for a
change it just makes the difference
don't it it makes the difference well I
promoted it man I did my bit that was my
job done
um what what would you want to be doing
in 10 years would you want to do
directing or yeah I want to be a
director 10 years time that would be
annoying cuz me me wingman not so much
film I'm kind of hoping he fails cuz if
he does I'll keep me wingman if he
succeeds if he succeeds I may get a few
movie roles still get some yeah you get
to play I mean I've been discussing the
man a few things off camera where now
I've sort of what I will do is write a
roll in for you uh so pil the ask then
isn't it really I mean yeah but these
roles are you know they're good meaty
roles for you to get your teeth into I
would like to do uh acting at some point
for just to see if I could I could do
cuz I think I'd surprise a few people
you know I'll write you into can there's
hidden deaths into this sensitivity
emotional um and then if not I'll just
do the hard man
[__] but the thing is you you probably
can break into bit Vinnie Joneses you
probably can sort of break into but just
more handsome funnier talented better
footballer got all of that why are you
talking about Vinnie have you got any
like bits of acting that we can watch or
I've done a little bit I've filmed a
sketch that might come out on my channel
unless it's [__] in which case you'll
see it in about a couple of months
obviously run out of stuff to upload
there was a great audition you did for
Game of Thrones the tongas that was
actually really bad I think it's going
do better yeah no you no definitely uh I
mean you would be a good actor I think
I'd love to see you sort of emerge in a
few films do you know or you know if
they ever make a sort of a a live action
Sonic the thing I would like to do is I
I would like to have a podcast that is
um self self-sufficient that isn't
basically funded by other people where
we get proper sponsors involved in all
of that stuff and we can do regular and
I can get everyone um because that
that's the problem with podcast it's
just hard to get the guests on that you
want so you end up S suffering these PLS
um but no serious it podcasts you kind
of help The Ransom of who the [__] you
have on so like I'm quite I'm selective
though but I'm saying at some point I'm
going to have to sort of scrape the
barrel on there at this rate we sort of
we you're heading there we're heading
there you're on your way no I think
we've had we got we've only got people
that we thought were interesting on
there's never a person where I thought
wow but I haven't to be fair I know
mostly people I found her interesting on
yeah I could have gone the route of just
just getting people who've got massive
audiences and we have we've maintained
some
creative yeah a little guy a chance
all right so anyway um so yeah I'd like
to do more podcasts and more YouTube
[__] and uh if the odd sort of film
thing comes along that' be cool but if
you could upload the hand on a regular
I'm [__] I'm actually nailing me
uploads lately so [__] you [__] you're
uploading more often than you've ever
done I am right now and on two channels
so anyway it's been a pleasure having
the lads on AB jent the Perry is and I
actually can honestly say I rate his
both really highly I think he's our
really top Lads top you
and I don't really Ste you
right you didn't write that in he so
versatile yeah that just proves he just
leaves a lot of that in when he hits his
head off the car door and all of that um
but yeah I I don't watch YouTube I've
make no bones about that but these are
two of the few Lads I actually watch
like every week so thank you very much
good content Lads thank you very same to
you same to you nice one it's only one
extra view I mean doesn't have to say
that but appreciate it YouTuber doesn't
count as 10 views where can people find
your Lads uh on street corners
um just where am I oh Steven T there we
go that's the one on Twitter and on
YouTube everywhere yeah Jack M
youtube.com slj with two A's why does it
have two a's it just Jack was taken yes
simple even as early as you got there
still [__] taken yeah yeah first day
you went Jack oh [__]
someone else confir all right well
anyway appreciate all the people
watching if you've enjoyed it hit the
[__] like button subscribe check
these Lads out and we'll see you
later